Hi
Very good afternoon all of you gas so came
Hope you all know the paper clearly.
gave a cracker
very bad question paper i mean see
I was wondering, how can this be so easy?
Is
What should we do today without further delay
The ones who are right are the ones who tell me first.
your paper
[music]
tell me how it will be
paper so i feel i all of you
are going to be very happy and we will have a party
Looks like I'm about to give up
Let's call our friends quickly
People are going to start you quickly
I knew the session was going to be at 2:00 pm.
it was so easy
Our paper was not solved in 5 minutes
immediately
it's that simple
So you are going to solve all the sets by
Dee Way
We are going to have an exam party today.
The answer is, let's quickly answer the first question.
people are about to start
No, it is not infinite, no, let's edit it.
edit
Which one went till sir and I sorted it
Take it out and I will submit my paper.
It is kept here, let's see, take it thoughtfully.
Sir
Other questions Other questions that you thought
that you know it was like this
So the first question that came was rate.
un i gas
van question number van chemistry tu three
Four Five Six Till And Six It Was All
Can rate came again physics then came bio
it was very simple
Tell me quickly about the new children who have arrived.
How was the exam? I am very happy.
I am so happy, almost 90% of my life is now complete.
I completed 100% paper, one question at a time.
has been solved before
Okay, so today's first question came.
The first question is visible to all of you on the screen.
Whom is it? Tell me first
What is the answer to the question?
What is given during electrolysis of
Water If D Volume of Oxygen and
Hydrogen evolved at the electrons r
Represented by See You and She
What is the ratio of give C and H respectively?
If he comes, tell me quickly what will happen to him.
Answer: You talk about electrolysis of water.
If you do right then electrolysis of water
What happens in electrolysis of water?
what is h2 what gives us h2 + o2 what
It is important to balance this
We are getting different answers, we are balancing this
If we do, how much will it be?
2h2+ o2 Right here the balance is hydrogen
There is also a balance. Oxygen is also in balance now.
Here you get to know their mall
what is the volume
Right, tell me what fibers you will get?
will come
So 1/2 then which option will be the answer?
Option C Yes C will be the correct answer
See, this is how the answer will be solved.
Will be done
Because what have you asked volume off
Hydrogen and oxygen should not be confused if
If you have made a reverse mistake then here B
Okay, let's move on to the next one.
on question
among the following
You will also get the paper
Whose answer are you giving the second question?
answer please
If yes, then if you guys don't tell me then
I have to tell you
yes yes yes yes yes
lithium sodium
Very good answer is option number a date is
Lithium
Very good don't foam in de chat box gas one
It is okay to give your answer only once.
Let's move ahead to the next question
Side
Now I have asked this question right here in the activity.
But you had conducted this given experiment.
Set up let us know in which case our
The bulb that is on the right will glow the most.
First is dilute, tomorrow is dilute
sulfuric acid glucose and alcohol then
what will happen here kids
We'll see how he does it when
You can get free h+ ions here only by getting Bull Blue.
The conductor will do it only when you know how to conduct.
If electricity is conducted here
What will be the answer dilute kal and dilute
Sulfuric Acid I also told this
Electricity in glucose and alcohol
If conduct is not right then answer will be.
In which what will come to us first and second
Only first and second only option
number c
will also be in dilute sulfuric acid
Dilute will happen tomorrow also
[music]
Please put the number also, ok then I will know.
Whose are you giving next?
We come fourth on the question
Question witch of d following give d correct
Order of increasing acidic strength OK
Is
There is sodium chloride here, hence there is water.
Null is also neutral Null is also neutral
Its pH will be 7. Acidic acid is acid. This is
If it is also acid then its pH will be less then right
I wanted to tell you about the increasing order of acidic.
strength first
Answer will be a
Ok
Suraj If you have yes then Lithium is the answer
Of course I took it, now the answer was you second.
of question
Ok yes yes yes quickly my friends
Call him and he also has to go, right? Answer
How did the question go or not?
Who knows, they thought the paper was very difficult.
Yes, let's move on to the next question.
Come on, I did this here too
In the class the day before yesterday, you gave the balance in these orders.
You have to tell the following reaction
Coefficients of so many reactions
Have written the composition of lead nitrate
And children on this reaction in paper
You have one more question, right?
Due to this, you will get one more question from here.
If you get the answer then what is the late night treat?
PBO what can you do in this case
Try substituting and look right here
what will happen 2pno3
On heating gives 2pb o plus if i
The first one is taken 4 no 2 plus oxygen
Right here you will see how much LED is.
Tu tu right full of nitrogen or nitrate
You can see how much nitrogen you can see
And 2 4 so nitrogen is four here
oxygen
[music]
This is the answer to sports already
Children, the answer to the fifth question is still there.
What will be the answer? They are giving 2 4 5.
are you guys 4 2
It will not happen, you will earn four, it will be right, let's go then A
There are answers to many questions yet, next we
Let's talk about one ethanol react with sodium
This is a common reaction, what will be its answer?
Sodium ethoxide and hydrogen gas
We have also seen the reaction here, so I
I will tell you quickly
c2h5oh when you react with noh
you get c2h5 on plus hydrogen gas
We call this sodium ethoxide.
Is Hydrogen Gas There For The Will Be
Correct answer is ok very good so who
It has been given, it is absolutely correct, let's go now
Next question is not from chemistry
So coming to the next question and sir
let's see if you call
It has been said many times that the best in magnetism
What is important is the right hand rule and
Left hand rule is the only two rule, so here
what is in this question
If positive raw then what is positive?
Something Similar Tu Electron Just Positive
Charge To Sam Positive Charges Going Up To
what does it mean current it in d upper
Direction is current if you are in direction
And this is D magnetic field so we have
Find what to do if you need to find out
D force when I told you yesterday
When you have three parameters you have that
Left Hand Rule Date Is FBI
FBI points out here
The magnetic field was this D's first finger.
Then second finger is d current current is up so
For example this screen is in your page
Like this page so you can thumb this
Pitting Inverse R in D Page So Correct
Option is option number c
ok i yes fantastic i gas this too
We had asked the question to Sir, right?
Question You Were Actually Doing It Yes
Exactly similar, it was fantastic!
Next question is about six
We talked about determination in every session.
Ki Thi Ki When N X Very Sperm
Red has brought expiring sperm
Fertilizers D Act So We Know
It will be done right
So what will the situation be like here?
Now where can there be confusion here?
Where might you get confused?
There will be no confusion in this now
Confusion you may have in A&C
Right, tell me what is the correct answer.
result
What is the combination of chromosomes asked?
zygote to s aay go means what zyggot
This is always you and that means ours.
diploid cell is in diploid cell
How many chromosomes does a diploid cell have?
There are total 46 chromosomes and
Thoughts Same Correct Option Is Option Number A
Fantastic Let's Go Next
question
Right
over here
she has to
Current Increase It Times Then If
Your Increase D Current By Too Time It Would
b h tu let's suppose give h1 so h2 wood b
Current is tu i d original current squared
and t so expand this bracket you will get
4 times i square rt so h2 what
h2 is nothing but four times h1 isn't it
So right now D percentage is asked here.
percentage
If there is change then what will be the change in hit h2 -
h1 so dis h2 - h1 / h1 * 100 dismiss
percent so what it h2 h2s 4 times h1
So Four Times It's Van Mines H1 What
Aayega Three Times Hit Original Divided
By original hit multiplied by 100% and
This h1 will be canceled this will come out
Hui
300% so it is option number
What will be the option number?
How can you go wrong by 400% change here
Wright is asking
Change has been asked, how much amount has been changed?
So this is option number B
let's move on to the next question
a physics sir om sir yes sir om slope again
From
Here it is explained that it is so difficult here
There is no question, it just asks
How to connect ammeter and voltmeter
So I did this very frequently
Was this one example then if this is d
Resistance is voltmeter here.
let's connect quickly tell me what is the answer
Its question number 10
series
Sorry
ammeter + - + - then what will happen
Ammeter is connected in series ammeter in
Series Voltmeter in Parallel Osm Next
question
chemistry chemistry
This is how carbon is formed here
one second let me make it again
So here in the middle of the carbon triple
The bond will be carbon in carbon and here
hydrogen and enter question number
123456789 10 A lot of kids said this
Six by counting only carbon carbon
You must have given the answer but the correct answer was this
10 Because the total number is asked here
off electrons, so children, tell me, have you
Answer C has been given to this question
write the answer like this
Chale biwi 11 ka b3 total number off
Electron asked for shares, not bonds
Have you asked how many answers will there be?
Total rights if electrons are shared then you
Will count six plus tu aate plus tu
10 then what will be the total?
This one was also sampled in the right sample paper.
It was asked in the paper that let's do photosynthesis
So you know where it happens the most.
This is the highest voter synthesis.
tissue where it is best to
Question: What is chloroplast?
Amount of Gases Exchange Express and
what kind of gastion
So where does it come from? Do you all know where?
happens from
If it happens through stomata then fourth option number
Option number B is right of question number 12.
Did you give the right answer? Did you give the wrong answer?
have done
Tell me the answer quickly and one more thing.
You are going to come to the paper, so you should not.
You will understand how many in your last
If you are going to get marks then that too
Tell me how many marks can we expect?
ok let's move ahead
Hey, that's the bio question again.
Apna question number 13 from set number tu
Which principal muscles do you present?
Dixit of water yes if possible
Not all children should know about Sprinter.
But they have asked fifty something like that
The options available are absolutely correct.
I have given it simple, I have given it simple, it has come.
Exit of stomach and small intestine
Stomach is ok stomach and anus so
Red So are not directly connected
This will go out of the small intestine and
any type of large intestine
System doesn't like muscles for
Controlling Rate D This also cannot happen
Clear cut now remains so figure stomach
And Stomach and Small Intestine So Just
Piston is the spice, it is the stomach.
And why between small intestine
Because the stomach is yours, whatever shop you ask is fine.
This is a shop, what will happen from here?
Then this goes to our diodonum rate, this is
goes diodynam creative goes
Apna Allium
stays in place so that the coin is yours
Partially digested food in a short time
There is a stomach for it otherwise the food would come from above and
It went straight into the small intestine
Film music will not be right
Fantastic Tha What See Want Right So Come On
Let's move on to the next question sir
which is the next question
So we are on the 14th question.
During various exercises
Simple dude extremely straight forward
Very simple question
[Laughter]
Hey that was a lot of fun man if you guys
If the paper went well then what more do you need?
We got the best questions from the computer yesterday.
Have you done competition based questions?
We did the last minute session.
And in that last minute CBSE people
The book was released in
information
Which fathers are examples of Philos?
Either he is very famous or not for this
unisexual plant unisexual plant
Meaning where there is mail here and there is flower here
If you are a female flower then Papa will be here.
Papa came once or twice, now what is mine
Mustard Red Mustard What is Mustard?
Bisexual is a great example
You know the flower discus
In practice, if there is sexual flower then
These are your two options
climbed like this
The problem remains in A and D, so its solution is
What is the answer? What is the correct answer?
That's right, that's it, my children are gone, sir.
You broke out and it was great and
Hey Max, you guys don't care.
It should be understood, if not then someone can write.
What is the use of giving it, man, if you leave it.
Someone has gone, this is wrong, let's move ahead sir.
let's go
it's done it's done
So here we have a convex mirror
Convex mirror looks like this, it is convex
mirror
Will diagrams come or of mirror or lance?
Question will come, diagram is very important.
It is important and you saw it in physics.
From the diagram at almost four and five places
he asked
very angry
Didn't give it friend, made the paper so simple and
All diagrams are Bhargava
Comics Mirror Object Is At Infinity
If there is this object then there is infinity.
According to de new sign commission de sign
off d focal length so what will happen here which
If incident is rage or parallel then which one is it?
The tower is a convex mirror of delay
diverging mirror sleep
point wear
Upper tu me des of focal point and this will
B our focal length so focal length is on D
Right See Are Going Towards Right So Date
wood b positive so what will be the focal length
If positive then first A and this jump
B Correct C and B Already Song So Nine D
sin of d image distance to image kya
The object here will be this Apna U
U Is Infinity And When U P Places D
Where will the object's infinity image be formed?
If it is made here too then it will become ours.
Where are we again on the right so both are
positive
Get it done so you are the one going on brother
whose is it now
Set you are coming brothers and my darling
sisters ok
will grow up properly
[Laughter]
So we read this because it is highly
If there are reactive metals then you can call them
What cannot be reduced by carbon?
Molten oxide can still be used
Metals Have More Infinity for Oxygen
carbon this is also correct sound
More affinity for oxygen this is also
Correct and date is the same you know they are.
Formed Tu Metals by Electrolysis So
Asarjan is also correct, Reason is also correct and
The correct explanation is therefore option A.
The answer will be OK, option A is everywhere.
Who has done this wrong?
Three on A are coming, no one left set
Now we will do the set number, you are doing it
It's just a matter of everything else I have questions about
But I will get it and I will keep solving it.
What questions do you have?
He is coming from here, as Silver is saying.
Rohit is saying that we have given our
Even in set three it doesn't happen that much.
There are separate cells, isn't the question?
If it is repeated then you also tell us.
That this was in my set too. This was in my set.
If it was there then we would also get ideas.
Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Right Right Do Not
Intersect is this one if they
you must have seen it
direct question
Be right, here you will get the magnetic field.
Do you know that bar magnets are magnetic?
These are field lines that never intersect.
All the work will go out from the North and from the South
If she goes inside, I will freelance intersect.
Didn't do it so the assessment is true and here
Region given magnetic field lines r
Imaginary Lines D Other Points Coming to the Legs
Give direction of field here
Take any one point you want here
If time changes then it will be in the direction of D.
If the magnetic field tells you then you can quickly
Tell And Reason It's True But Will It Be A
And Will It Be What have you written?
if mother take
magnetic field lines intersect
For example this green van this in D
The setting will be where there is intersection.
What will happen there, two directions will be formed
What is the magnetic field and region?
If there is only one direction
So the magnetic field lines do not intersect
If it does then this reason proves that
Assasinif Correct So Answer and Option A Ise
d correct
I don't need a pen
Result of Tu Bacteria Divide Again
four two's four one's two two's four two four
Right is a bacteria and its division
If two are made, two are made, then two are made.
What does this mean? What does this mean?
They are talking binary here
Asexual reproduction of fashion is okay
Very nice so D for bacteria
Produce Would Be Almost Similar We Know
what happens in sexual reproduction
If a right similar is made then there is hope then brother right
Looks like let's talk about region's region then
When we read, we pay attention to two things
I have to keep the region in mind as to what is right and what is not.
If you think the region is right then DNA is the right region.
Copy Inverse Small in Accuracy This
Reproduction process is small in
Accuracy is correct, region is also correct, rate is correct
So what
But is the region the correct answer for D?
What does adsorption feel like?
What do you think
But the reason is not right for the given one
Social, so what will be our option number in this?
very good pal-palak di rate very good
I am calling
[Laughter]
what happened i am coming
Come on sir, next question
Traveling from myopia, what is it?
This is what happens in this eyeball is ours
If it happens then the range
In front of the retina neither is myopic
Person Cannot See Distant Object Clearly
Asarjan this true near object design
But here's how to correct this
we here we have to do that
Concave Lance Which is concave lance
Diverging is what they said here
Is Converging Lens Date It Wrong So Reason
This is a wrong assessment, you are reasoning this is wrong.
And yes, the answer will be option number C.
Great, many children did well.
let's go back to physics after this
So you will also come here, where will we all go?
Sir, section number B is on A.
Gas we are on section number b
And all these questions aset van tu three
I also have one hand and two changes, the rest all
So let's get it right
So here it is asked one and where ten d
Rainbow Upper in D Sky So for Example
If you have your san here then race with san
Aayenge and this is de water dropped na
So will go inside the water droplet and this
side he will reflect then when and
Where the Rainbow Forms So When
The answer will be mostly in the day when it rains.
Just After the Ring When There's Water
Dropless Present in the Sky and Where
Where is the opposite side if the san is
Behind me rainbow will form in front of me
So opposite tu de san to ye to first ho
let draw de la blade diagram
Let's draw a diagram of this
So how will the level diagram look here?
Instant Re you have to write this complete word
ok incident raj go inside d water
Rocket What will happen after that?
refraction
Refraction So This Single Light Dies Un Height
Light White Light It Splits Into 7
different colors
So these are from rate tu wallet and this
Phenomena called forward dispersion
Don't you remember all these names coming here?
Points of reference today well today
Dispersion and Atay De Adar Name What is
Happening D Region Total Internal Reflection
and just right internal
Reflection and after date D race will come
You de service again reference you have tu
let's draw all this
Like water if you're right let us see
Let Us See How It Came Right
[Laughter]
out of this
What is Scattering of Light Scattering
what happens
without light falls on you particle
Different Directions Date Called It Us
Scattering of Light This phenomenon is called
As Catering of Light
And the sky is blue in these
If you have a question about your mother, please give it to me.
My favorite question is always asked
lives
That BS Blue and its answer is ours
What happens in the nearby atmosphere?
Which gases are giant gases? Nitrogen
And oxygen is gases and molecules are
Are smaller in size so when the light falls
On tu de small particles small
particles molecules what happens d
scattering
Scattering is inversely proportional to
lander is you for what is this lambda
It is a wavelength whose wavelength
The Wavelength of Color is the Smaller It Will Get D
At Most There Are Seven Colors From Red
Tu Wallet Wallet Haj D List Wavelength Red
Has a maximum wavelength so every see has three
Colors Blue Indigo Valid So All Three Off
Dame As Caught De Most De Get Scattered
Most Hai Na But Nine Same Of You My Ho De
Question's viral sky is not wallet end
Answer for date is your things you need right
forces
If ice as sensitive as you human eye
Sensitive Tu Tu Blue Color
And Wallet And Not Debt Sensory To Us And
D Second Region D Spectrum
Tha is un sunlight dat com from de light
Date com from de san it has this region her
This is the blue region and it's very small
Region of Indigo and Violet So Maximum
Like Which Come From De San Blue Color And
Date Is Reason If You Come Mind All Of Days
Regions this is d region same d sky is
blue ok
let's move on to the next question
Number 22 Coming Up Super What's Un What
Like you know this question has been asked
what will happen if
Gaige first of all question mention tu uppal
Do loving de change today thank you so much and
Friend you gas right who are saying that
Supported you are glad you supported you rich
Not only til everyone wants this as well
xylem tissue
In un plant remove it brother xm
what does we do what is gauge what
Do this I love you tell me when will be set three
Set three will be done now, you finish it then three.
Then there will be a van, there will be a four, then there will be a van.
sign up what is children xylem what is
Up flow of water in our plant
Keeps It Right Is Actually Caring D
flow up of de water now what we said and
Do you know how xylem is? If we
You will not see the section in this manner.
Side-side is okay. Side-side.
I am jealous and when I cut this
Jaelo off if you think you have barked at someone like this
If you have cut it properly then you have
jellum has been removed rate jellum if removed
If given then water transport will stop
What if water transport stops?
Wilting will happen, what would happen
Welding and Death of the Plant Plant
What is it, he will die, he will die, he will be fine
so what will happen here
Death of the plant is accidental, isn't it?
Will be and right wilting and distance good
Tell the next question CR is injured
And start bleeding has come upon us
You fell from the bicycle, you got hit and there
If you get injured then tell me what happens.
What happens what happens in debt case
What happens in date if injury occurs
Case I come for all of us Case I come for all of us
rescue
tell me the answer friend
Will the platelets come? Will the platelets come?
What does clad platelets do when they arrive?
do formation
platform do like a platform
What happens is the flow of blood there.
Let's plug it in fantastic so
Next Question
potassium iodine nitrate chemistry
Ok now let's move on to the next question
What is observed when you get the solution of
Potassium Iodide and Lead Nitrate R
Mixed together, this is the question
nor did we think
Have already done it three-four times in class.
I used to tell every time here DDLJ
is a double displacement reaction
If not then what will be potassium here?
You have solution of iodide and its reaction.
This is the end of the date from late nitrates.
o3
If you have solution then its ok in reaction.
What will we get from Product B I2 Date?
LED Iodide Yellow Color Salt and Us
will get kno3
You have to balance this reaction as well
Why to balance? Why to balance?
Have to do because it has been asked here
Right D chemical equation is potassium
Nitrate is in balance and iodine is fine.
It is yellow in color
So this is a mixed name de type off
Which reaction is it, kids?
DDLJ double displacement reaction
ok right the chemical equation chemical
Ok if I have written the equation then this will be done
So tell me the answer to this, have you guys?
I did the right thing and asked one more thing children.
Secretary, when will set three be in a while?
Will happen as soon as we set you will cover it
later we will fix set van and sec three
Wait a little, let's move on to the next question.
In this and in this when copper powder was in this
Heated in a watch glass without black substance
Form Direct Questions So what here?
What would happen when the copper powder reacted
Copper oxide is made from oxygen.
Black in color is the same as black substance.
Form name it became so because of which copper
Solid is right it reacted with oxygen
So what did we get? We got copper oxide.
solid
ok what will be the balance reaction children
You will add here. You will add here.
Will give you the right to see once till the cross always
should do ok after that it's black
What is the name of copper oxide?
Reverse tu its original form and jitne
people are also getting correct answers
What you have to do here is like it
Tell us about your session and also in the comment section.
Is this question our right?
It's okay, you can take the next black substance.
How do you rig back that copper?
Oxide solid has been found, we call it hydrogen
If we react with gas we get
goes back to copper solid + h2o right f some
Reaction happens here, ok now here
But but you don't have to put the hit sign.
If you want to forget then there is reaction balance. Yes yes.
the reaction is balanced ok
Okay, so this is the answer black.
We told how it happened and why it happened
[music]
what is the next question
If you want to cross check then you can see that also.
ok to take
Man, who asks such easy questions in bio?
hai bro ok capital t capital
keep doing it with tijamanas
So Capital Di Capital Di would look like this
Not as much as our children, they feel like this
Sir, madam, we have asked all these questions.
have put on
so it felt like this
If you have asked then F1 generation is nothing but this tu
The answer to the first question is what is D gene?
Combination gene combination is asked genetic
If you have asked about the combination then are they Heteroids?
We will write heterocycle s
All 100% long toll give reason only.
Tall Plants Are Observed In
Brother, we know the law of domino law of
Domino
ok then where is what would be
The fibers come on so my children at night
Even if you wake up and ask, they will tell you it is red.
We know how the F-Tu generation is.
There are two ratios which we call fino
teepee
How was the phenotype? Phenotype 3 is tu van
end zero type
nothing friend
1:2:1 That's Right
thank you sir
Next Question
fantastic
nine see you have him right hand thumb rule so
circular loop here this is uncircular
Loop Something Like This and Let It Ling On
A horizontal table for example something
Like this there this one circle look every like
On this table and the current is anti
Clockwise so this is the direction of current
And clockwise isn't it so every draw d
Magnetic Field Lines Show Direction
And D Pattern So Aate Every Point See
You'll see every point coming, you'll have a thumb rule
Right Hand Thumb Rule So I'm Thomas Pitting You
D Direction of current so current is going in
This anticlockwise and what is happening
D Full Lines Are Coming Out
Full lines are coming out from upper face
And let's go inside go back something
Like this is so this is a part time
So you have to draw this pattern every
Something Like This Would Be Patterned Off
d magnetic field lines
Tha Sahit And Three Marks For You And Tu
Marks let me next question yes
Going down they are going here okay
Next questions please
What is meant by traffic level
Nah, this is the rate in the punch mark pocket.
What Is It Mean By Traffic Level Gauge
What's min by traffic level what is it
It Nothing Sees Doing This Topic Level
Topic Level Write So Very Steps in D
What can we say about food chain?
This Is D Keyboard
ok you know food chain
The date is tropical level, isn't it?
Give Tropic Level Date The Tropic Level
Next Van
on average
Anand Average What Percentage of Energy
Transfer Trimmer Limit Locked You Know What
This Is The Answer For The First Van Over Her So
This question was for ho me tu marks
So Van Van Mark H So Her See Have Van
Questions and there you have and so far
What was the previous answer BB and Van Was
10% law
Dependent on rock so 10% of energy is
Give transport which category is off
Consumer du d'organism of secondary
Tropic Level Belong To You So Yes You Can Gas
What is the answer for date secondary
Tropic level so see has primary
rate so first tropic level t1 t2 so de
Have asked T2 t1 this definitely
If there is a t van of plants so plants then
T2 Wood B
t tu wood b
Happy Way Animals
tha all
OK gas, whose answer is correct?
Correct button let me see let me see ho me off
ur able you are bringing a hot hot paper inside
Now the second set has come, just do nine ok.
Do the paper coming in the door just for fun
It is yes sir please keep it date and
D Next Question
Right See Will Sun Go Just Know It's Un Right
In Side So See Will Just Start Solving
Okay, we have paper A in our hands and
C r just solving dam ok yes yes yes
Sir
Mostly I'm checking our set as well
So hot-girl set has come right down
So section B C and D almost from that
All questions are similar except A.
Some questions are different so you just check
Read the Question Her and You'll See It
Can be set a b c d question will be
Is it similar?
Fantastic So Nine It's Chemistry Balance
And asking de doubt for this yes
Chemical balance equation for the following
And identify the title of reaction then
What will we do here children?
Nitrogen gas is created with hydrogen
Gas Tu Form Ammonia Gas Balance Ki
Write the chemical action of nitrogen gas.
If already given then here N2 gas plus h2
gas
Give ammonia gas ok now balance it
It is very important to do this, if you don't balance then
will get messed up because mentioned
Have to balance right so here if you
You are three here, you should take a look once.
Nitrogen balance is hydrogen six.
Hydrogen six, this reaction will be fine
After that you have to write land nitrate
It is heated strongly by LED
plus nitrogen dioxide plus oxygen
If the gas is fine then what is land nitrate here?
It happens
pbno3
When you hit write you will get LED.
oxide date is b o+ no2 + oxygen so
What will happen here is solid, it will tell you
What will it give us here it will also be solid
This will be gas and this will also be gas so today you
Reaction was given in the same question
Isn't that when you hit lead nitrate?
So what will you get if we get I
If I tell you that question, it was in this
We have question number 5th I said
The question has been repeated so you just have to
You have to balance from here, you are here.
our answer will be late
are you here
Okay kids, it's clear, this one is coming now.
Are you updating the copper wire?
We took copper in silver nitrate
We will put solid plastic agno3
Shining on deposit and silver is
What copper will we get if it is produced?
will display it and we will get it
copper nitrate
no3s plus together we will get silver
Solid so this one is the reaction here
We will have to balance the reaction to get it right
So how will you balance here then here
If we have copper the nitrate is double if here
But we will add it here, you can check.
Do what is the reaction balance?
Yes, we are solving you and setting you now.
Set three will come quickly don't worry ok
So these reactions have happened, this is our answer.
Whatever be the set, always see all the questions.
I am almost like 80% questions off
So any set c are doing de set tu butt
80% of the questions are just arranged there
difference
Yogesh
Question board also asked yes it this way
predicted
Isn't it D Harmful?
rate ok so d house full chemical things date
Enter a body through food chain what is this act
What is date it is de finofena is called
Ahead
Biomanification ho me of you are able to oil
date this is about
Biomagnification happens when you sleep
Dee DDT Is Getting You No Accumulated
Over the food chain and next topic
Level date is called today bio magnification
Right so you are still confused?
Which set is running Apna set this code
This is 31 2 2 of your set, so go ahead.
I am doing fine, it is true that you are moving.
Right now and the set van is in our hands just now
Hot Hot You Have Arrived So See Will Do Set
Dear Set Van Immediately Right in Three
fantastic
Fantastic Four date identification date was
This question is of three marks right so
van is for date and den a is di
Concentration of this harmful chemical found
Maximum in human being because of D
Phenomena of biomagnification where it
Increase Right It Increase Through De Tropic
levels end
human beings human beings etc part
off
top most tropic level
Hans Di concentration is highest in human
Beings are what you want to do
This yes let's go and next next question
let's go and student hajj focus the image are
1 minute
Is
[music]
So Just Focus Everything You're Doing Set Number
You and What is Given D Students Have
Focused Object Height This Un Height of D
Object Height of D Object Is Premium
He is using a concave mirror so this is
Ho de concave mirror look na its focal
The length given is 12 cm focal length.
12 Centimeters And You Remember If It Is
What will be the concave focal length? Give negative
C Have D Object From D Mirror 18 Cm
So this is d object axis location so
this and f witch it date 12 and this is set
24 So the object is bringing center of
Curvature and D Principal Focus So You Would
B mines 18 cm
Values ​​so see you find distance
Off the Image Simple Formula I've Told
It's time de ville etliste van
Question from D Mirror Formula and Length
Formula And C Have D Question Told
I did not
Formula Van Buy B Plus Van Buy U Ise
Van by f tell me what answer did you get
for d image distance
Tell me quickly, there will be a van in the van.
By S - 1 / U What Is F Focal Length
this-12
-12 -1 / 18 You are mine's incorrect so this
- Will Be Plus and What It D LCM Off
12 and 18 lcm is 36
So 12 * 3 Wood B 36 - 3 Give 18 * 2 18 *
2 is 36 so + 2 - 1 / 36 what is this
Van By V So From Har B = - 36
Centimeter Nine C Check If This Is This 12 So
C Is Aate 24 So Image Is Image
Correct and this image
36 cm right you can verify today well this
Show this correct nine height of the image ho u
Find out height of d image
Different color see no magnification equal it
tu height of d min by height of d
object
height of d image by height
Of the image would be mine what is we is -
36 - 36 / What Is It -18
This is multiplied by height of D
Object Given Us Three Centimeters 3
Centimeter and this will come out you will be mine
Six Centimeters So What Ten Date Tell You
Date Tales U D Images Inverted and D
Size of images six centimeters so
The height of the images should be 6
Centimeter and answer for this is mines 36
cm and 36 cm from de pole so this
Wood b d answer great and sam yes yes se tu
do it first
I have a question from B, we will not repeat.
Questions about what ever they do
You're not going to solve it again Joe
There are only different questions, only dose
Have you solved so like watch from d
Beginning and if you find same question witch
Are Similar Just Check D Answer for Date
Ok
Power of Lenses Van by Focal Length So
What is this definition as per your CBSE
Book de power of un lance define it further
Reciprocal of de focal and just this
equation what is power of lance it is
Reciprocal of D focal length nine D focal
Length is -10 cm Focal length is -10
Centimeter So in Meter What See It Will Be
0.1 M So If You Use This Formula You Will Get
Van divided by - 0.1 m - 10.5
And what is the nature of this lance
Power is negative meaning focal length is
Negative so it means this is un concave
concave lance
Pomegranate
Distance of 20 cm from D
Optical center according to new ok
C have a concave lance less draw c very
Rather
Very happy so D focal length is every
Let's have an optical center this F1 is
2 F1
f2 and 2 f2
ok so where this object is 20 cm
Object is at this position this is inferior
Object Right So See You Just
Reed diagram if d race parallel to d
Principal Axis It Will
Diverge and going through D optical
Center It Will Pass Without Other So Nine Were
this is the image this is the image
So you can see the images upwards
Objectives Also Upwards So Both Are
vertical both d erect so both are positive
Their height is positive so what see you
Find out D Magnification Sign of D
Magnification What is Magnification Height
Off D Image Divided by Height of D
Object and Both of Dame a Positive So
Magnification Wood B
positive what is d sign sign of d
Magnification is positive great ok i
Now Next Van It's Fantastic So Gas
We come to know that he is the one doing this.
Analysis: It is necessary to analyze so that
How much more can we do in our next exam?
You will know how much you have to score and how much you have done.
Okay, how much preparation is needed?
Whatever is gone is gone, the night is gone, the talk is gone, do nothing.
I am okay now but I am very happy
Dat you gas are doing really well right me
Look at some of your answers which are very good.
Next Van How to Explain This
Direction of movement of growth in
Response tu de touch un to ye growth hai to
C have dan growth meaning kya tropic
Movements Red Growth What does Tropic mean?
Movements Add this topic Movement which is
Due tu de touch is called today
tropic movement
With whom?
Tell whose tendrils these tendrils belong to?
Just write for you so that you can answer this question.
Dan this during these practices right
Come on, who is this brother, tell me such a reaction.
Do Joe Neutralization and Precipitation
both will happen
Has any such question come up?
I don't know why, if you want to know then tell me.
[music]
Let's go with the help of chemical equations
This is common between roasting and calcination
Question is set in sector van and said tu
There is a different question in three, is this?
Metal Reduce from the Products You Know
Obtain after hosting in calcination of
D World Right D Chemical Equations Kids
One more thing section A B C these three
There are different questions left in the sections
This is from another image and that too questions who
Is different from is different by one or two questions
ok then we will discuss now
Don't worry, your set will also come.
Going to do
I told you this, now we have to tell you about roasting.
And children, I have made a difference in calcination.
Was hosting already done?
It happens that we take absence in hosting.
Off a Sorry Presence Off Air or Access Off
in the air
So this is your difference calculation
For whom do children carbonate and
For and here we react given
You can tell action off air example
Zinc sulphide then azinc sulphide if you
and then it will react with oxygen
You will get oxide + so2 gas right
This is our first reaction after this
You guys will do the balance next carbonate
If you hit zinc carbonate
What will you find here who
Oxide + CO2 gap so we have these reactions
I have told you that this is the first part.
Metal is reduced obtained from de product
After roasting of acid roasting and
What do we get after calculation
After hosting and calculations we got
Is it an oxide or is it an oxide?
You have to convert it into full metal.
I hit you with carbon
Ok
If you do this then the oxide you have got will be
If you react with carbon then right
What will you get with Zinc Plus?
Our part is done, now you have the chemical.
I had to write the equation here, you wrote it here.
Something else is given which was not given in the question
ok one more thing can you tell me
over here
If you are interested in our Highly Reactive Metals
happen when you hit them with carbon
If you are not able to reduce then its
What will you do there? Displacement
Can also be done through reaction like
Manganese oxide is and if you with
If you react with aluminum then
Displacement reaction also gives you complete
metal will be fantastic
Hi
They have done everything but let's see
What is a solid and how does it look?
You would know this, wouldn't you?
Ho de solid looks so from here if current
will go
so what is solid tell me what is solenoid
Un Coil Off Mini Circle Loop This Not Un
In the single circle this is the cuckoo made up of
Circular loops in which current is passing
In this direction it is made so dat it
Looks Like a Cylindrical Shop So This Is
Called us solenoid hai na what is it
solenoid then you have to write all this if you
Don't know the definition you can just write down
D steps it is an uncalled made up lot of
Circular turns or arrange true date de current
Passing it through in the direction
And so third point d shop it like this
Cylindrical shop to ok nine draw d
Diagram Tu Show D Pattern
How will the pattern look something like this
Inside d solid c have a uniform
Magnetic field and outside de magnetic
Field Lines Will Be Something Like This
So Van of Dem Will Act Like a North Pole
So Magnetic Field Lines Are Coming Out
From Van Side and Sam Adar They Are Going
Inside Date Will Act Like a South Pole So
This is D diagram for D field lines nine
Name D Region of Uniform Magnetic Field
So in this where do you see and where you find
Uniform Magnetic Field and Answer
For date is inside d region inside d
Solid will have uniform magnetic
Field is great, it's very simple, three
steps three marks
Nice so next markar questions date is
Question No. 33 Thank you so much sir
What is the first step of breakdown
Off glucose 100 times list right?
Breakdown of glucose during D Arovic
Respiration and anaerobic respiration so
Glucose Tu Pai Rohit Glucose Tu Fire Un
Wet witch is called today for
[Appreciation]
33a1 Right so d answer for this is d answer
For this is very nice Harsh Fantastic
glycolysis
Right D Answer for This Is Glicock Listens
Where C Breakdown D Three Carbon
molecule glucose in two carbon molecules
Give R Three Carbon Molecules of Wait Again
They Have Asked Question Number You So Do You
Full This This Is Out Of This Syllabus ATS
Called As Energy Coral Sea Of D Cell Vice
I have full sleep
No no, the answer is only
Glycolysis is the only thing they have done aerobically.
And anaerobic respiration you get d
Correct cycle is not the part of aerobic
Respiration anaerobic respiration it is d
Part of aerobic respiration it happens in
Mitochondria are fine so no this is yours
The rate is given in a yellow colored box
ATP and ADP then ADP is converted.
ATP is converted to ADP where
Break Down I Do Phosphate So Plus Van In
Organic Phosphate See Remove and When This
This is happening when breaking of ATS
Happening Van Postpaid Molecules Getting
Cut down the energy and release it.
disadps again recycle tu atp ok
So how will we write the answer to ATP C?
Will Right Date Provide It Readily Usable
Energy Too De Sales It Provide Ready
Usable Energy Too This Very ATP
Breaks Van Off D Phosphate Molecule
Releasing the energy to date energy is
Between date band yes first answer science
debt remains in
the lungs
after
After Acceleration After Acceleration
Date it called ahead Rijiju they have not asked
u same
So They've Kept It Very Simple Dem Not
Ask you the same because it shouldn't be
alauddin tu call apps thots same right yes
I am also waiting for you very much
This is a very good question, thank you for asking.
Sets Too Be Cute Difficult Please Let Us
No In D Chat Box Gas You Tell This Set
Isn't it a set number, you are enough for me
Lendi feeling ok set number tu me
Looks quite lovely what about you guys?
Please tell me your opinion
Yes, this question is also from bio.
The fact and the question I have come up with are red and
The activity they see is this, isn't it?
We watched the activity session.
tha rate to yahan pe yahan pe van answer what
About Adarsh ​​Set Number Van Yes Group Ye Abhi
We are solving the same Rohit 31 Tu 2 So
See are doing set you let's see let's see
You can see who has the majority.
What do you say children till then I will do this
Let me explain, okay so sunlight is this
Essential for photosynthesis so they have
Asked you to complete the experiment there
vas du tu
Complete Experiment Over Every Red D Set
This is the question of you, are you doing this?
Is Again There In Set Van Aaj Well Right C
Are you going to do that van set after this
and
If there is a repetitive question then what do we do here?
Let's do this first by keeping the plants in the dark.
Let's take a healthy plant
in dark room
keep in dark room keep in dark room
How long do you keep it for?
24 you keep 48 horses 24 you keep 48 for today
So this is basically where the starch is
Completely taken off nine ok this second
What do C Tech D plants do in steps?
out and over the leaf and on d leaf c
put un black paper rate hum wahan pe kya
let's put black paper on it
Ways to Date Sunlight Connaught
Reach D Thing Right Give C Have Step Number
Three Range Exposed Tu D Sunlight Nine C
Exposition Tu De Sunlight
Ret si exposed tu de san light and
After Van See Once See Exposed It To You
Sunlight What Will Happen to Her and Her Photos in
This will happen but this segment where this
No sunlight enriching photosynthesis there
It won't happen so in the first step what see
do see do d the color
I Hope You Remember D Color Right and What
Do Sea Do Sea Violet First Sea Violet
First write violet in water give violet in
all
And every step there is a mark butcher for
Every step date you have written should be
Un mark red so speak it in de economic
Right hand in D and fifth step add it
iodine
Rate C Add Iodine So After Adding Iodine
See you have right so this one the steps
what did they say right de sequence of
Steps of Experiment Steps H Step
Hes Go Marks Not one to be missed here
Okay, so here we have after this
What do C do D observation sleep in
Observation What Do See Date D Part
Which was not supposed to remain on changed
Rate no color change or no color change wear
rd part which was unexposed tu
Sunlight So Blue Black Color Asian
This light is important for
photosynthesis
Right
[Laughter]
Chemistry question
You can learn chemistry here children
In the question you we have finally come
Section di pe right to section di pe
Now we have come to section B. Five have come to B.
Easy question on marks children
People have already asked these questions in class.
I've done it many times haven't I and have
Said and Alcohol Rickets with each other and one
What do they do when they react to others?
Parathas are in the presence of a catalyst
We make sweets meningitis which we
Raid Identify X A&S says
It is a very easy question children, carbon end.
First of all you know from its compound
Write a Chemical Equation Inward and Name It
So just as you thought, sweets, I
substance means what is this ester yes
Very good so aster hai x
Yes, it is alcohol and also sodium ethanol.
Gave you that bye alcohol so a
what is alcohol x
Very good so what will happen to us
three x three three
ha tu oh ss
If we write its chemical reaction then it will be like this
Acid will go, this will happen, what will happen this?
Alcohol and after that you will get
What is the name of extra reaction children?
The name of the reaction is yes very very good Ethle
Ethanol Exactly What's It Named Of
reaction children name of reaction will be
esterification so
ch3cooh when you react ch3
What will you get from ch2oh, you will get h+
Effect in Presence This one arrow if we
If you plant it, not this one, this one will come.
van
ok so what do you get here
ch3co
right after that
oc2h5 You can actually write ethyl
ethernet is ok its name will be
Write five is your question write everything down
aana hai x ka ba x kya hai a kya hai
What is Wright Catalyst, children?
Our sulfuric acid will be the catalyst.
It's Harsh, very good, very good Harsh, let's go.
I wrote the names of nine chemical equations.
Told you the cerifications
What is this substance? So this is our ex.
Yes, this is our A and this is our S, okay
Sodium hydroxide in sa and pret
Produce Back Sea Alcohol Same And Sodium
Ethaneate Write the chemical equations for that too
You have to name and justify that
why is his name
Sir, you were not set here, you were not set here.
Yours
Something will happen, this is how the match is happening
The paper has come brother, let's go, we are talking.
What will be its next reaction after this?
Next reaction will be for us if you
let me say
[music]
Children, are you not making any noise right now?
has been
So
ok ok
What is
I have already told you what X is.
our ch3cooh
ok one to three one acid right
what is this reaction called
Saponification
This reaction is non aaj saponification and
Why is it called because D reaction?
Used for the preparation of socks
That reaction is in the preparation of soaps.
It helps, that's why I called this reaction.
goes the saponification reaction as much as I
If you have told this till now
If everything is written in the question then definitely
You are going to get full five marks
ok ok right now you will see in it na
And I had one more question and that too discus
I will do it, it's 5 marks.
Question everything is written
Ok now let's come to the next question
So you will come to the next question
Name the simplest saturated hydrocarbon
Now you are seeing no four in this
If there are parts then maybe one half of it
There may have been some confusion among the children in the part.
So if you did the first part in this then
It will be good for you, ok but no problem
Let's not see what will happen to it Name D
Simplest Saturated Hydrocarbon Droid
electron dot structure what type of
Bond should be there on the first part
Simple hydrocarbon gases are saturated
Methane date this ch4 his name will be methane
You will also find its electron dot structure
The right thing to do was to make Electron Dot.
Structure Carbon Hydrogen Hydrogen
van electron van electron van
electron van electron ok its
After this this and this okay electron dot
The structure was to be a duplicate of this
Bhi Duplet Ish Bhi Duplet Ish Video
plate and its done
Our electron dot structure
Very good Rukia if you wrote it in full
Right, you will definitely get it here.
Tell me what type of bonds these are
The bonds here are
Which bond is right off our covalent
valiant bond very good here it is
First part now coming to second part
Name Other Mixer of Carbon Compounds
Used as a fuel in daily life of the above
Mention compound which should contain basically
Tell me about such carbon mixers
Right please answer the question if I
Where No It's Written Where Have You Written Noh
wait or where did you write
It was very easy but if someone bought a second van
If you have done it then you have to look a little carefully.
question marks in parts
we will definitely meet, ok methane
If you have to tell its composition, it is methane.
In which case will there be a children's one for methane?
Hai CNG Compressed Natural Gas and others
is biogas
Because our compound from above has come
What is that methane? I had to tell you this.
A compound that behaves like fuel
do and which must contain methane
ok let's go
In which homolog series of carbon
Compounds can this be placed in
Will call this compound methane right methane
If so then we are doing the third part
What will you place methane in then alkene
Right here in its Homolocus series
The saturated compound that will come in alkanes is
What is the General Formula General Formula
It will be cnh2n+2 ok let's go and D
Last question which type of flame is
Produced Kiss When You Burn
type flame miligi we read
On burning saturated hydrocarbons
What do you get clean? Do you get it okay?
So in this way if you have collected all the points
you must have written, you must have left something
So give him the according part to you.
You will get marks if the answer is complete.
If it is written then you will get full marks, ok
Yes
It's clear let's go
Let's move on to the next question
Next question has been asked from some bio
related
So the children are still asking that we
Which paper are they solving?
If you are solving the set then look at your country.
There are many different types of Jones.
There are different series, so ours is like this.
This is a series, this series is different here.
We are solving this series
series is
Okay, so the series we are solving now
Which one is that?
This one is doing the series, you are doing the set, we are doing it.
Hain set tu mein kya hai code apna paper ka
this is the code ok
2/2 This is the code, okay, so we can solve it.
are doing
So this is what you are doing right now
Alright gas let's get into this so this three
Points Difference Between Novels End
hormonal mechanisms control and
Coordination fantastic very simple
Diya Hai Let's Solve It Now Will And Chemical
If we wrote then first what do you think
What is the difference between neural and
hormonal coordination gas
Third point inside if you want to add this
What can we say that yes brother who is here
nervous system is
Very true, so what we say here is that
How does information flow here?
Information is electrochemical
through impulses
electro chemical
How is this information spread here?
is spread using chemical messengers
through
Rate How We Do It Here
Vaidi Chemical Messenger
What do we call order like Holmes also calls it?
are so these are the three in this showing un
Pickle Dominance Aate Miz It Is Secreted
bye d
Meristmatics Rate C R Un Which R
present on d tips now what
Where is the oxygen secret?
Oxygen is not secreted where sunlight
This falling where s oxygen is secreted
In this area where it is dark it is okay
d dark area
And what will oxygen you will oxygen
Actually maximum of sale over here
What will happen here? Cell number will increase.
Will grow, will grow, will grow, very much
What will happen because sales are here?
Comparatively you this so this we and one more thing
It is said that those and distribution of
What are those oxygen called and
Distribution of oxygen on tip off
the growing shoot
But it was right let's move on
Sleep Disorder and I Came to Hope
You left this one and did the first one.
If you have done this then it has become a bit tricky.
Can because ask two things here
Disorder which a person is likely to suffer from
Rate asked to tell the disorder due to which this
Name of the disorder a person can travel
Tell me because of this one three situation
Also Name D Gland Date Secret H of D
Hormone Mention Above Can You Start
Answering son over secretion of growth
What is the secret of hormone then growth hormone?
What happens and what happens to it is defined
Road deficiency of estrogen in female
What creates estrogen and if
What can happen if its definition is achieved?
Has less secretion of thyroxy so
What does thyroxine create?
Gland Oxide Come On Fast Ho Is D
Timing and amount of hormone release
Regulated explain with help of
Example of Both of the Things You Have
Understand Nine So Her What is Happening
So growth hormone is secreted
nice picture
secreted by
what will happen from this what will happen from this
Over secretion is happening. Over secretion is happening.
raha hai so in date case what happened in date
Case C Will Phase Dysgendism
Which means that their growth is very dragon tick.
This date becomes very long
Gigantism is a deficiency of this
Trojan estrogen is secreted through the
Ovary is secreted from the ovary and
Deficiency of student can lead you
irregular
Menstrual cycle it can be perfect
Process of Ovulation Ahead Well Defective
ovulation
Okay, if this happens then it's enough.
All problems occur if this trojan
If not then there will be week bonus if this
If there is no Trojan then the voice becomes Gan
Cardiovascular disorders also occur
But this is enough for class 10.
give it
Late thyroxine is secreted by
Thyroid gland and hypothyroidism
Causes What Wait Jane Wait Jane
Weight gain due to slow metabolism
Because thyroxine is involved in what
Metabolism of Carbohydrate Protein
And fat is involved in all metabolism
Happens nine ho is d timing and amount
What is the correct answer to off hormone release?
The only answer is the feedback mechanism.
Feedback mechanism and then asked that
Explain with the help of Example D
Example will give correct gator also
It happens
So what will we call the feedback mechanism of sugar?
when we sugar
And when insulin is high and sugar is low
Let insulin be high and sugar be low.
pancreatic un sell it and give it what
Stops secretion of this
Hormones So This Is The Answer For This
Yes all the questions are not there in
Maharashtra Board I Know Date Right
Mansa Board's syllabus is slightly different
Right and it is not just that all
Direct given like this in CBSE
Questions but from the topic I still know.
The date is from Har Kuch To Hai and the topics are many
Se are name de type of mirror
Hello everyone, let's do a physics question now.
Let's do question number 36 nine.
Was should be used in the following images the
Magnified and virtual image of an
object so here we have virtual image
Which mirror is required and which mirror is used?
For a magnified image so you can see it
Tu Mirage Concave and Convex So When See
Its a concave mirror if the object is between
Focal Length and D Pole This is D Object
so image would be this would be d image nine this
This virtual and magnified image is the answer.
For This Would Be Concave Mirror
And if you let him unconvex mirror you
Can place objects in other positions images
Will form between pole and de focus so this
this d image this is our image so nine what
R D Properties This Virtual End Rate
Diminished Virtual and This Un Diminished
Right so this would be convex mirror
nine
Level Diagram You Justify Your Answer So
Let's make a diagram so c are this one
Object first very which is parallel to d
Principal Axis What Will Happen After
Reflection This Ray Will Pass Through Focus
You Can Take It Backwards Something Like This
And nine ok i remove same parts her
ok let's read raw complete diagram write
Diagrams for D Concave Mirror
I have a concave mirror there
Object F&P Object
First Ray So Let's Suppose These Loans Are Un
Reflected Ray So You Can
Extrapolated Backwards Andar Re So
There Are Different Races You Can Choose And Rake
And me an ray which is passing through the center
Of curvature or de ray which is falling coming de
The Poll So See Will Reflect Like This So Nine
Deez Tu Raj There Diverging So
Extranet This Van Again Backwards This
A point where we meet and this would be over
Image Hai Na Draw First Label Like So
What will happen which is parallel to you
Principal Axis After Reflection It Will
Upper tu divers from de focus and andar
Towards de focus this van is directly
Towards D focus it would be parallel to D
Principal Axis You Can Extrapolate
This Backwards So This Is A Point Where
deez tu
You meet so this van would be our image
correct so this is what you need tu draw these tu
Diagrams Clear
Concave Mirror Isn't It And See You Want To Get This
A Real Image But C Won't Magnify Further Well
See Want Magnified So Where Should You State
d position of d object so where will you
PP Object If You Have a Concave Mirror
This is un poll focus and send off curvature
Nine Again Let's Revise Everything
Sea Have Focus Object Beyond Sea Image Wood
B F & C & F But It Would Be It
Is Not Magnified It Is Diminished You
Place of C Image Wood B Se Size But If You
P Place Object So This Object Between
C&F So C Have Too State D Position
off d object
Sosis of D Object Is C & F So This
will be image
So this is a real and magnified image
Ok
You Should Not Beyond Tu F2
f2 and 2f1 date will come in de lance is un
Mirror so in de mirror you have tu place
no is the answer
We
If you have a question then next question.
A has been 37
So a teacher like us
got the practical done and gave the children three
Divided rights among the group
Solution to find out df and classify
Give these acidic basic and neutral are ok
Group B and Group C like this
Divided ok kids ok
[music]
Man, it means a little bit if you connect.
You write D topics, okay you have completed your final.
The answer is not the same even though it is not written slightly.
You will get similar marks but completely different.
Wrote the mirror's question, Lance wrote.
Like given in physics then you know what
What happens if half your question is written
Meaning any question has half answer
It is written if you are a good student then give it.
Will Cut Your Marks If You're Unpure
Student means just about to pass.
Will give you marks then this happens
Solutions are provided which include
Group Is And Are Likely To Have Value
Give less 7 and greater 7 then tell you
Which of these groups does F belong to?
Lesson 7 will come and the variety F which is greater
Give 7 will come tell me what will happen with it
Answer Group A Lemon Juice What's in Lemon Juice?
Citric Acid is Vinegar Acidic Acid
If there is a drink then what is there there too?
It is acidic and that too Group A.
So who is going to come in Group A?
Will come in this then we kids will talk
Here is the answer to Part A.
I will write it here in the first part.
Group A will come and we will have to check
Group B and C because this and R are written
Meaning, it could be one, it could be two.
Right Next Tomato Juice Coffee and Ginger
juice tomato juice again it is an acid ok
Coffee Ginger Juice So what do you think?
Give it less coffee to 7 children
Dates are acidic, same here too
Our group B will go to A in this you wrote
Is it not written that group A will also come as group?
B will come right and give greater if seven's
You are talking about sodium hydroxide
is sodium chloride is li me water is
Sodium Hydroxide Strong Base OK
Neutral is neutral, tap and this is line.
water line what is water children
calcium hydroxide
If it happens then where are the Group C people?
will go
Right, this part is done, you are in the second list.
Way of Determining D of Un Solution So
This question is un van mark again this also
Van Mark's was what will happen tell me 2s
Of determining f first if you wrote
If it happens then there will be a paper.
The right end is the second F scale.
So f scale and f paper so f paper which
Different different colors are right
Different different colors are universal
Indicator is correct for paper and second
What will be the second method f scale which
What will happen there from zero to 14?
You have correct concentration of hain and on.
Determining Df
Ok yes in this you write litmus paper here
Can't you see litmus paper is the indicator
It tells whether it is an acid or a base.
If you want to expel the acid then exit
If you want to leave then what should you write here?
Can universal indicator which is
Paper and if you write litmus then that too
It will be fine because no one can tell you the reason.
To get out then if litmus you did it
If it is acid then it is PHLB Lesson 7 and it is basic.
It will be more then seven and third method is
That if you have a scale of tea
Be it concentration or China's concentration there
You can also tell by F. Okay, let's do this.
This part is done now, the next one will also come.
So let's go to the next question.
This third part was in your choice.
Ok then let's see the explanation
For substance as lemon juice and effective
End Cleaning Tarnished Copper Vessels Children
We have asked this question in class
why does this happen this happens because
What is the reason when there is turbidity due to copper?
Children are born with brown and copper is
But copper carbonate is formed after
Dates are of darning green color.
Basic in Nature Very Good Copper Carbonate Is
Basic in Nature and here Citric Acid
Sorry Lemon What's in Lemon Juice
If there is citric acid then there should be an acid base reaction.
Will go and whatever our cleaning whatever
If there is dirt, you will be able to clean it from there.
If the right is simple then the acid will neutralize it.
Base of Copper Carbonate and Our Vessel Will
B clean ok we did this one
Didn't do it in class if you are regular
If you are a student then next was next to him
I also told you about the great importance of Hajj.
It was told in the class that what happens to F is
It is very important in our life
How can you give an example?
It will have acid rain when the water level is 5.6
If it is less then we call it acid rain.
F of soil you know F of human body
We talked about when you were right for three
It happens if F is less than 5.5 then it is called
There are many points given in your book.
You will write any 2 points among them
So you will get 30 marks in this
It is clear, did everyone understand? Yes, you said it.
Yes, I took this acid rain and broke it.
you can write
Bad
Well, this was our last chemistry lesson.
Question Now we will come to the next question
Who cares about someone who is not into chemistry?
I have a question
[music]
okay and sexual reproduction and sexual
We know reproduction well
way or thank you
Right, what question did he ask here?
I have asked you to leave this
Here type of fecian name d type of region
Debt Acres In Lakshmi Menon Or And
Plasmodium You are a simple question
We have also discussed so very good bye
Woman
very good son binary and multiple
[Appreciation]
Right vantage of sexual how much is asked van
If you have asked then there is no need to give much.
Very Good Very Good Very Good More Variations
Peacock Variation
it was very good, very simple
let's see the next van
So it is asked that give reason, give reason.
Same so same question red so this
R is basically called concept based
So if you have understood the question then
If you can solve these questions then
We say concept based questions
Look how it is asked. college of east phal tu
Multiply in water but multiply in sugar
The solution I did was concept based.
Calvary is in it so long and wide east
I did it even then I said that this
The rate will definitely come, so what do they say here?
It is better in sugar solution
If it can then why can't it be in the rest?
if could
I will get his marks in written examination.
But please answer me, it is correct ok ok
Piyush had asked if the flow chart was atlist
If you have given numbering then it is also fine
Even if numbering is given, it is fine, ok so
Give Rhizopus individuals yes what about this
The answer is that it is a carbohydrate.
Sugar is Food Rate Sugar Gives an Act Like
Food provides energy, hence give resopus.
Rhizopus means how broad is the meaning of red mole.
What Do Not Grow on Dry Slices
off
If you have your toast then it is right.
Dry slices have no moisture
There is no moisture which is very important
Arrival or growth of fungus in our East
Give name de filament to happen
Structure Student Identify and
Collecting de water from pond which is
Dark in colors and filament structure are some
I remembered this Spirogyra. I remembered something.
Sparrow Non Jahan Pe Spiral Shop's
If there is a chloroplast, what does it do?
This is very good next
Shani's very good very good very good
Anupam, here you will get full marks.
Got I Can Guarantee Date Raid and this
how to divide
Educated third heart was see no worries
How does it divide when it is new
What do we call it if it becomes individual?
Fragmentation is said to be true for everyone.
The answer is going right, let's move ahead, what next?
Let's move on and see the next question.
This was very easy, I felt like it was bio
These are the six easiest questions of
Right Hanji Himanshi has come in the segment
If the science exam is over here then
Now we have our Physics one.
The question is
Difficult ok let's find out set tu do
It's the same now because someone is lazy, yes ok nine
Every this is the only question I find ok
Little Beat Challenge In For Physics Because
All the questions till now are all D
Questions of Very Straight Forward
Directly from your NCERT textbook
ok last question
Read Comparison See Only This First
Comprehension Very Easy Write D Circuit
Looks Beat Communicate But Let's Analyze So
Nine Consider the Following Circuits So There Are
Nine identical resistances all of them have
Value three ounces easy ok get it right sorry
Three on value for all d resistance or
Connected comes shown if reading of D
Ammeter A1 is one ampere so let's suppose
D current which is passing through every is given today
Van ampere so nine this current will split
In these you resistance so this voltmeter you
Just Attach and You Can Remove It So There
Won Me Much Current Taken Out From D World
meter so nine current is passing through this
Voltmeter ok so only this current will
Split in these days you know it will happen again so every
I also have a van amp
Okay So Let Her This Kind Will Split In
The free resistance comes again at this point
Have Van Ampere D Current Will Split in 1
2 3 4 Resist it Will Connect Back Again
So C Will Have Van Amper Her
visible high is it visible
Right Down Using D Blue Color Everything
ok van a
I can call him black or black is visible ok
great sleep
Using This Diagram So See You
Understand D Questions Where It D
Question what is the relationship between A1
And A3 So Relationship
What can I do is I can just exit D
Slide Show and Download This End
Will Also Be Updated Every So Just Download
let me download
If yes then download it
import download yes ok download
I do editing
[music]
ok ok you finished
Wasn't able to write so I have just un
Son ok every van impier nine visible right i
Can Write Everything Every Van Amp I Can
respect him color today well
ampere
Van ampere and 1 mp so nine i have not
Har This Point As P This Point As K Har
This point is here and this point is OK
For different points so nine
D Current Har Is Van Ampere D Se Current
Comes out in D A3 so let's find out van
Of d question by the way what is d
Relationship between readings of A1 and A3
What will be the relationship between these two?
D Relationship You Look Her and Have One
Current from ampere and D comes out at A3 so
3 Will Be Equal Tu A3 Will Be Equal Tu And
A2 & A3
What is this relationship let's look at this
There A3 which is one amp you will be
Mach 1.5 no ok voltage ok welcome back tu
Date so look every day ampere current is
Split These Four So Let's Call This Aaye
I one I you I three and I 4 ok so
Total current i which is nothing but van ampere
And write down every van ampere this current is
Split In Four Five Saree I Van Plus I2
+ i3 + i4 ok but nine looks come this
All the resistors are in parallel with five
Potential difference between all off give it
Let's Call This Potential Difference As
SAM V3
Potential difference so because of because of
Potential difference from this
I can write as d total current i which is
Flying through this can be written as de total
Voltage Divided by RP Do You Know RP
Is d equivalent resistance value and
Every I Can Write i1 Time Free Is i1 Will Be
Equal Tu Total This v3 / 3 Oh v3 / 3 Oh
Similarly I Can Write I2 Us
I Tu Us v3 / 3 Similarly I Can Write I
3S v3 / 3 Similar i4 Will Be Three
Divided by three so nine what do you
observe every
All the currents are equal so we can write
This As This Equation Haj
Total Current I Will Be Equal To
passing through ammeter
I Van Will Be Total
Current it is wan ampere so this wan
R/4 and 1/4 of D ampere and 0.25
amps so this is the reading of d
ammeter tu
Let's go to D Question what is D
Relationship between a tu
D Relationship Between It And A3 Will Be D
current measure
Current Measure by A3
Date is D Relationship and You Can Write A3 This
See no A3 is one amp and A2 would be one.
Bye
zero point 25
clear
so let's go back her
Voltmeter V1 So this voltmeter does nothing
But the current is passing through
Through this circuit multiplied by D
Equivalent Resistance So See Can Read Raw
This Just Only This Part I Will Read Drop
So it would be what are your points this
Point P and this point K so between P
and k this point p and this point k so
Between Dees Tu Let's Suppose This D Single
Equivalent resistance RP so this RP
I can write it as a van by RP us
Nine What Are You Resistance 3 and 3 So
They Can Write
you divided by three
Divided by the Ones So There Is D
Resistance value of DRP but what
This current is given as one
ampere if d current it van ampere what
Will be when it won't be equal to you
ir i have you ons law
tha is d current which is van ampere x
Equivalent resistance which is 3/2
oh so what will be the voltage it will come
Out you will be multiplied by 3/2 which is
Just 3/2 sorry 3/2 volts and 1.5 correct
1.5
volt so tha is the voltage
This Dejan Look Like a Continuity Base This
Like solve this kind of questions lot of
Dem Just Date It Looks Very Big Question
Right ok so nine let's go back ok d answer
For this wood b 1.5 volt nine d last van
Find D Total Resistance of D Circuit So
What is total resistance?
what is this this oral can see what
Can Do Is Her Is There Is Un P&K
And write down solid for points p van
Resistance and K and Adar Resistance
R And Third S So This R D Three
Resistance and what are solids these are
Equivalent Resistance Between P & K
End Equivalent Resistance Between End
R and between R and S so there you are
In parallel so what will be this is each
Resistance Between P & K Date Would Be
Just 3 / 2 oh right two you three on there in
Parallel So Do See Just 3/2 Har
Nine second van dee's three there in again
Parallel So Aarti Would Be Do You Remember
What would be the RP equivalent
Resistance for days three
Divided by Three So That Will Come Out Tu
b
three divided by three ounces
And nine d third van har c r three ohm
Resistance And Ho In Of Dem For So This
Will Come Out You Be Three Divided by Four
oh so nine these three resistances they are in
Series So D Total Resistance Are Total Wood
Be just come dem 3/2 + 3 / 3 + 3 / 4
lcm is 12
so ho mach
6 so 6 * 3 = 18 +
so 3 * 3
History of This 3/3 I Can Write This Are
Just Van and Van by Van
Buy Van So Nine LCM Is Easy What Is
LCM 4 So 3 * 2 = 6 + 4 + 3 Aaj It Can
B6 + 4 which is 14 An6 + 4 which is 10 + 3 13
/ 4 This is D Total Resistance Value 13
/ 4 oh ok
- 1.75 No Dec 13 / 4
yes
3/2 is 1.5 + 1 + 3 / 4 is 0.75
And just add
Off de set and let's begin another set
yes so whom
Down in your answers
It will start now, it will start now, your set is fine
So what is it now? What is it now?
own
Correct
Has been basically doing this since 38 years
Nine ok since 38 years so see have all the ranks
And 25% of un students are already in
Arbitrated
So this is what lies behind the link gas
For you people which is for ji right so ke ka
Bhi Hai And For There Also You Get All This
Export Faculty
24/7 Doubt Awe You Also Have
Life classes which are record giving are super
Teachers write assignment is very fun
Test analysis is not only this, friend Paren
teacher meeting meeting with your teacher all
By doing some one-and-one analysis, you
Mock test is given, they will be
ILTS which is All India Level of
test series this date c conduct just get
you are
They are present both for 11th and 12th
Grade which is described in description box
Just before C goes into D next set D
Badges Are Already Going To Get Started
Right D Earn Batch of 2025 with this target
In 2025 is being started for grade 11
Similarly if you see the next van rates
So this is for 20-24 this year kids who are
This is also very important for those who will be in 12th.
Okay, so all this stuff will be important
what do we do right now let's go
What do you say on the next set, ok now we
What do we do next let's really go
Which set do you need first? Set Van and
You are set, you are set, I am now mine, yes.
You are set, it is three, quickly tell me who.
Let's do that one first, yes
Majority, you tell me, both are ready.
Okay, the rest of the people also tell me, friend, the rest of the people
Also tell me what will happen now, it will happen immediately
you, we did a lot by spending a lot of time
because there are a lot of questions
Repetition with is there also, so now we
will go with a little more speed
What questions will you solve now?
Will solve only if there is similar question
We will tell you the answer, whatever is the final answer.
And you like you can go back and you can
Re watch it d se question ok to chalo se
three
Which set is to be reduced sir?
Well it's closing ok let's set the van today
Name sir ok so witch of the following is an
example of
Across this different question was formation
Off snake gland then children formation of
What was snake line? What was combination reaction?
Okay, which is exothermic, so this
The one will not be the first one is xo
Second the composition of vegetable peas in
We thought compost was being composted.
Hey what will this be? Will it be N2 or not?
There are no eggs just to confuse you.
What is this also xo? After that
Dissolution of ammonium chloride in water
So children, this is the reaction, isn't it?
Solution of ammonium chloride
Ammonium Chloride and Water When you are here
If you put it in water you get so
Plus plus tomorrow- so this is our reaction
What is this endothermic reaction?
After last digestion of food in our body this
What is exothermic reaction?
Answer: What will happen when C date is dissolved?
off you ammonium chloride water is ok
let's move
I have already told the answer to this.
If the answer is yes then we will not do this
previous set
sodium in
hydroxide so what do you get
what is its name kids what is its name
sodium, what will be the answer?
B for Bombay
Next question: This has also happened
We did the answer, the answer will come Lithium
A Right now let's come to the next question this
is new
number of electrons
Metal, if anything is non-metal then its
How many electrons are there in the outermost cell
Can you guess which one will be the first one?
Three is non metal 1 2 3 will not happen children
Why wouldn't it happen because it was made of metal?
is sodium magnesium is aluminum 123
There are electrons, this won't be ok
After that there is 3 4 5 3 variety which is 3
So that is also metal in our aluminum.
This also won't happen, now come 567 yes
Non-metal if we talk about nitrogen 5
Valence Electrons Oxygen 6 Chlorine 7
Then our option number will be the answer.
will do five
Next question, now the bio has come.
turn yes yes
Principal present coming from what exists
Question from set number to stomach and
Small Intestine Again D Se Question In
This massive of Witch of D following diagram
Gas exchange occurs through stomata.
Stomata are on the lower region of the leaf surface.
If so then stomatas rate will be from here so
Where is your option number b thought correct
Fantastic During Various Exercises
Question man, why give something like this in your bio?
I don't know what these people gave me, it's okay
Witch Wear D Unisexual Flower and D
For this is watermelon and
papaya very good whin x wings
The thing to note here is Zygote.
Ok if it is a matter of zygote then it is complete
The set will be 2n hence the answer number
A Correct 44 + X and X Un Girl
Child Okay So Date Is Convex Mirror Again
D to Repetitive Questions C Have Discussed
And answer is option number given for you find
Out D Focal Length D Convention for D Focal
length and for d image
write down question
how will it be
Shivani Vishnu Harsh ho is your paper
Is in series voltmeter is in parallel
He had written many times on this PC
Percentage change is called change mass of you did
Don't Read This Word Change and D Change Would Be
300% ok 4
I am saying Yashika you did not read this word
Change It's Next Mine's Original
date is h2 what is h2 h2 will be
h2 Would Be Four Times h1 So Change in D
Sheet Wood Be You - H1 Which Is Three Times
h1 so change 300% nice vishnu correct awesome
So everyone has given this question just date
C have every positron so positive ron it
positive
Charge and D Answer Would Be in D Page Nice
Mistake OK So Essay Reason All D Assessment
Reasons Are There Are Not Change Anything So
Sodium Oxide I Chemistry
It is the asarjan region, it was changed, said you.
I was different, this is different
oxide so kids what is sodium oxide
amphoteric oxide is not sodium metal
What is this? Basic oxide is right.
So if this is basic oxide then we are done
So we have a couple of options save date this
Di ok, still see this one metal
Oxidase will react with acid today well
We call them amfutoxides.
The first one is an absolutely correct statement.
Our false one is our second one's true one.
Which option will be correct? Option given will be given
Correct answer is ok let's move on to the next question
This is a bio question, tell me your name.
I have a question about Bacteria Divides
In this then what will be the result?
Will remain different, will remain clone, isn't it binary?
fashion reproduction close up dna copying in
By the way, small in correction is also correct.
True but due to infraction
There is no point here, basically single
It is the parent so any changes are there
Doesn't happen if there is sexual reproduction.
If there are legs, there are parents, then there are two.
When jeans come, the variations increase.
Thoughts, that's the correct option.
Because both social reasons are true but
Reason is not the correct explanation
For Association Next Question I
i ok my piya
Connaught C D Distance Objects Ras Correct
But this does see the converging lens answer is
No Result Region is Incorrect So D Option
The number should be as if you reason it falls
yes correct fall
You can see objects near and far
Objects Are Not Visible Concave Lenses
Her date is diverging lens nice vishnu
Correct Nine D Magnetic Fields Do Not
Intersect This is Correct and D Region Region
Is Also Correct It Is Not Just Correct
Explain Same D Magnetic Field Lines
Connaught Intersect So Both Association Region A
Correct and it is an incorrect explanation
So option number A is correct, so like.
Hit Karo So Ho In Off You Go 20 Out Of 20
It's good, 21 is different, I am of you.
go 20 out of 20 question paper code kya
Is
w2 it un series and set number
van picture van tu van
I just came here and have a question for you.
I am done, let me tell you quickly here.
If you mix late sorry potassium
Iodide and lead nitrate are yellow.
Whose potassium will we get color PPT?
End name of iodide D type of reaction
You will have a double displacement reaction
If we want exact chemical equation then we first
I have done it then I also told you this
Copper Oxide Hits You Know Copper
Copper oxide becomes black.
Okay, to read the reason, you
get the reaction done with hydrogen ok
If so, we will not ask this question.
next one
means have done
[Laughter]
[music]
In the first set we did set number tu
If it was not there then it is said that it is the same
Important you prevent oxygen and
Deoxygenated blood if you remember
You Remember These 150 Important Questions
Which we made important in last 50 questions
The oxygenated was discussed there
Blood from mixing in birds and
Why is matter important right?
This is delicious because of our Sita.
The rate that beats the heart
Septals are there because of that and the end is there.
This right and left that changes here
why does that happen?
So We Need More Energy and If There Is Another
Mixing of oxidized and deoxygenated
Blood D Hard Wood Have You Work Faster Witch
This is not correct then next question
asked
Next question asked is which animal cannot
Tolerate Sam
Mixing of oxygenated end
deoxygenated blood what why we dollar
How can you not rate CR Exotic?
What is our entire body?
Are we warm blooded animals?
Warm Blood Animal is Yes So See Can Control
The body temperature is continuous in the same
Question asked and what factor dose given
Body temperature of this animal depends on blood
Circulation Blood Circulation Controls
Body Temperature Right So See Have Warm Blood
Animal on the other hand one see talk about the fleas
On Where Sea Talk About Dishes and Aquatics
Animals
Are warm blooded animals are cold blooded animals
They can't change body temperature
According to you outside and wireman and
That's why there is no need for double circulation in them
I don't have to worry about it.
i four chamber oxygen
Bye Puri When We Cross Puri
So capital T is small T in F1 generation.
How to Stay 100% 100% C Get D Dominate
Rose Aay Goes Dominate Previous Answer Capital
t small t came rate nine first answer came
Capital T Small T means Heterozygous Dominant
See Have Dan This See Have Dan This Very Nice
Epic Witch Region Same Only Plant Law Off
The answer to Domino Second is the Law of Dominance.
What would be the ratio of plant obtained
In F Two Generation Genotypic and
Phenotypic ratio with my eyes closed
Children can write I know this is this
non fibrous fibers
and van it
zero type
Behind on d and side of d san end
What happens in this D Ray White
Light it refracts and disperses then
There is internal reflection and there
Refraction So All These Phenomena Date Happen
Inside D Water Droplet So This You Have Too
Draw Perfect Weight Diagram So I Have Dan
This Question I Will Not Spend More Time On
let's go tu de ya seven class de form
There dispersion you have to write down
everything
give dispersion internal reflection
Dispersion again you have to right nine this van
This is right this van is wallet ok yes awesome
great
Nine D Next Question What is Catering
Have dan this van also and same de sky is
Blue Because in Air See Have
Hari Om I Look Like But I'm Not
Light falls on the particle it scatters
Date Means It's All Different
Directions It Is Called As Diffuse
Reflection and Scattering Wireless Gas Blue
Because they are molecules date it
Nitrogen and Oxygen Gases Gas Small
Particles So D Lower Wavelength Scattering
It is inversely proportional to lambda
Raj tu for lambda is un wavelength so
Lower Wavelength Blue Indigo Wallet Wood B
Scattering de most but de blue color is
Very sensitive you and is compact of violet
And Indigo And In D Spectrum Of D
San It Consists of Manly D Blue Color Not
D indigo and wallet date is d region sky
this blue
Next Van This Is New Questions File
solve it
Hey what?
Voltage vs Current So Know What It D
Slope Have Dan Exactly Similar Questions
So slope wood be slow full be voltage
Divided by current so do you know from d
One's Law What is Voltage Divided by
Current it is nothing but resistance so slow
Please single tu de resistance so nine si have
A&B So Which Van Has a Big Slope D
Has a greater slope so resistance of
So R of B Give it Greater R of A So
date is the first question i gas ok so
Nine I both have the virus at length
From diameter to length and from time to here and from late
Different Resistivity What Is It Length
And Say Time So I Can Write This Are Us
Cross section will also be and this is
Greater Than I Can Write This Resistance As
Resistivity of A * Length / Area So Nine
Because of the length and area it is you can
Cancel It Out So What Do You Left
Resistivity of B greater than resistivity
Of a so which material is higher
Resistivity it is this object will have
Larger resistivity great so justify your
Answer You Write Down These Steps So Thoughts
ho you justify
The Great Nine I Whose It Is
new question
Was this question done or not?
Tell me, I was feeling like you were coming.
Also we asked 150 questions sir right
The papers of all the zones are sitting there.
Right yes so basically same do not clean
Ponds on Legs Button Aquarium Knot
Dance
Every answer is correct there is no voltage
Versus Current You Gas Get Confused I Have You
Hold His Very Number of Time
The graph so what is its slow slope is
Voltage divided by d axis
Divided by X axis was this
Resistance slope is directly
Proportional tu de resistance so nine dis.
This Object B So It Has Higher Resistance
Object A Will Have No Resistance and
What is de resistance you can say this
Formula Resistance Nothing But Resistivity
Multiplied by length divided by area
But Length and Area D Equal So Can Cancel
It out so what you get resistance of
Is greater and resistivity of a U gas i
M but sir thoughts same d give this slop this
Come I was free and I was a tax to us
Sir you must have made a mistake
heater cd they have there is no hit right
Higher resistivity this high not hit
Ok I can continue thank you so much sir
For clearing doubt the answer is you
I know the first thing that comes to people's mind
Am right all of you must have dropped it
This is because of system red because
It's a Mother Made Ecosystem Her See Doesn't
Have Van Sitting and Respect So See Do Not Have
Different Tropic Levels C Do Not Have D
Composers over every date this same mother
integration u min integration is
Required over every
fantastic
If it was different then you know section
It was different and after that you talked about Max.
You will do it, it's different, it's okay
There was nothing different between Di and I.
Question of section three is silver
Chloride Kept in a China Dish Tons of Grease
Unlikely, this question is asked very often.
People have done it recently also
When We're Practicing The Silver Chloride
When you leave it aside, it becomes D.
Hindi presence gets composed
Sunlight is fine and what do we get here
But we get fire plus C and you get gas
Right here it will be solid and this
It is solid, it is white in color, children.
And this is gray color okay with
Because you have to tell the color, write the color off
Silver Chloride When It Was Kept In
China dish color what would be silver chloride
It's white in color, it's okay after that
It will change to gray and will be left open.
So it will turn gray okay with the reaction
If you balance it, it will be very good.
Balance ho hai tu silver tu silver cl2
Name D Type of chemical reaction very easy
Which reaction is decomposition?
Also specifically photoelectric
If there is a composition then the photo will be taken here
litke bcom position
Now tell me the uses, what have you written?
People read us in black and white
Photography is very good so it will come here
In black and white photography
We react to it, it's done now
Let's watch the next part
Yes, which chemicals can do that?
So if you have written everything then you will not get any
Can't resist meeting three times
AGBR, don't write and come here, this is a mess.
it will be done, I wrote it
But maybe the mood is good, it's okay
Isn't it 1GB? Let's move on to the next question.
towards
This set of chemistry is common in you.
Question was difference between roasting
And calcination then roasting in d
presence of air is ok
Calcination is Hindi Absence of Air
And this is fine for Carbonite OS
After that we were asked about its reaction
I have previously explained
House metal reduction can be seen from there
From product to hosting and
You get oxide from calcination.
When you hit the oxide with the carbon
ok then reduction is done you get
The entire metal chemical reaction goes through me.
You should get it solved from there a little while ago.
We can see, ok let's go next
let's move on to the question
Answer Right What is D First
Answer for this what is the first step in
D breakdown of glucose during aerobic
And anaerobic respiration so dat d se
Thing Great Glucose Ray Molecule Piru Vet
Two molecules of which are three right
Correct Chopping Field So Date Is
Give Glycolase if you have glucose
Pyramid is written you have written gliss both
D Things Are Correct If You Gliss Too
It is written that you will get the mark only then you will get glucose.
Pyramid is written only then you will die and where else is this?
This is where it takes place also
Question has been asked in this tax place
Cytoplasm: Where is Cytoplasm located?
plasma write
Fantastic ATP Call It The Energy
Currency of sale is also called it.
It is called because what does ATP mean?
ATP and ADP I How Explain You Right
ATP and ADP ADP what are these two?
Let's keep recycling and you know
Sine triphosphate is converted into ADP
Date is Adonosa and Dry Phosphate you get
These organic phosphates which break down
If the phosphate bond is broken then
There is date religious energy there
The small orange colored box over there
This is given in your books
What is meant by Rijiju Volume of Aa
The amount of air that is saved by breeding
Air Left Behind After Acceleration
call it forward
Rijiju volume of air
Ok
We can proceed now this is what is asked
Right D Sequence of Step Off
Experiment where sunlight was shown
The Essential Photosynthesis Video
You can check by reminding if you have just
Joined I Have X Plane Late R
All these steps and in this you have to
Basically Right All the Steps Cute Painful
I'd rather come if I'm giving a paper
Wood rather suck the first van, isn't it the first one?
And if yours has not come then you wrote this
So here we know what to do with you
What do we do with the plant?
Keep the plant in a dark room
Keep in dark room for 24 2
24 you
48 Then let's bring him out and let's see
put on black strip over rate on black
strip over rate and
Let's cover it so there's sunlight here
Will not go give c exposing you d
Sunlight and give remove this leave then give it to him
Add ethanol to water to color it violet
And what happens to chlorophyll from there?
Add C Add Iodine Add Iodine
What will happen after this part?
Here no change in color no change
These colors and this one is black blue
will go
Thoughts It
Tell me who attended this van?
Who sees such a big problem? Okay, let's go.
Next Question Sir Name D Hormone Release
Yes
New Van and Gland Witch Great
Secrets It Human Beings During The
Scary Situation During This Carry Situation
Ho dose d body respond tu enable it tu
Deal with the situation, tell me which one?
It happens
now it is right
Don't know actually
fantastic code very good sanika which one
What actually happens is that it is on our kidneys.
The right date is like a nice hat.
Come really and be ten
Digestion System and Road Transport
Vishnu doesn't slow down, he becomes fast.
What does it actually work with?
Heart will reduce the heart by going to the heart
Heart rate will increase your pumping
Copy exercise will increase heart rate.
What does off blood mean? Access to blood is yours.
Body Mins Access Off Oxygen Access Off
What does oxygen mean? More energy. More energy.
It means you are ready
The butterfly that must have experienced the rush
come right out digestive system slow
When it happens, what happened next seems like
Yes Right Now You're Having the Good Bowl Movement
happening but but the major thing is with a
The supply of blood is increased.
Is
Fantastic Let's Next Un Student Haj
focus image
Fall in de set number tu and I will just
Write down the final answers where the answer is
D Image Form It Would Be Mines
36 cm and height of d image wood b
Mines Six Centimeters
inverted inverted image ok
Questions I Have Dan This You Can Just Go
back and recheck
Alright define de power what it power off
Un lance c no d power of un lance's just
When My Focus and How You Define It Powers Off
Lenses Reciprocal of D Focal Length Date Ye
Outer write down if d power is -10d sorry
Focal length is -10 for wood b just 1/-
0.1 Have This Is Exactly Say Have Dan
Meter Which Is - 10 Directors Okay End
Sine Convention Have Dan All These Things You
Can't Just Go Back and Read Sheik Yes
Meaning of overloading ok this is new
Question So I Will Take Same Time To Solve
it
What is overloading? When does overloading occur?
When it happens so what happens if
Let's separate live wire and neutral wire
If this is you come in contact
Give overloading in electrical circuit
Kos Wood Be First Garden Wiring Bed
wiring
AND SECOND WOOD B IF D INSULATION KIMUT
insulation
come out
Because of debt you are live and neutral
Wire Might Coming Contact And Dt It D
Region overloading happens and after
Overloading What Happens Then There Is Another
Short Circuit So Lot of Current Will Come in D
Neutral Wire Which Should Not Happen When This Is Un
short circuit and d next question is
Van Preventive Measures So Ho Will You
prevent
Ho will you prevent using an fuse you
electrical fuse i.e. it
Electrical Fuse You Just Put It In D
Live Wire Fuse So What Would This Do If
There is overloading and if there is a short
Circuit D fuse won't be broken once again
fuse is broken no more current in d
wire so this is what you have solved
great
Alright de next van chemicals from
Ho Explain Ho Sam Harmful Chemicals
Inter and body so gas this question is also
Sam from de previous set date c have
Discus Previously See Head Discus Set
number tu nine c r discussing set number van
right so every
Basically harmful chemicals that are inside us
A go rate dose is because of what dose
Are because of what d
Biomagnification Very good news about Ravi
Red Very Good Beta Bio Magnification
Next question date they have asked is the same
This concentration of harmful chemicals
Found Thou Maximum in Human Beings
Why there is more substance in beans only?
It happens because you know that human beings are
Aate de top most of de topic level na na?
Tropic Level Van Tropic Level Tu Tropic
level three t van t tu t three and three
Four Red So Every You Have Human Beings End
There Rd Maximum Level of Traffic Level
Thoughts the same maximum amount of non
Degradable biochemical waste is
Accumulated over there's the same
Biomagnification is high over there yes now
Chemistry yes I am ok kids this one
This question has been repeated a lot by us
bar the esterification
He is the one who has come here, so I will do this already.
I will tell you the solved solution
Quickly complete details with equations if
If you want to know then you will go to this video first
rewind you will get it
Acetex is our acid here.
ethonic acid
ch3cooh alcohol is our ch3
ch2oh
Reactly Teacher in the Presence of
The catalyst here will be acid.
sulfuric acid you can take
We know the right chemical equation.
If we write chemical equation we will get
Which is an ester whose name will be right
Ethyl Ethaneate OK So A
Fruity smell will be sweet and small
What is the name of the reaction esterification
There is a reaction, I have got it done many times.
After that in class when you see him again
react with sodium hydroxide
So what do you get again?
You will get our salt of acid and alcohol
So that's the alcohol, you will get it back.
and will get together
ch3coin a ok that's what we call
Sodium Ethaneate Good hence the name of action
What will happen children? What will be the name of this reaction?
Saponification And it is also necessary to tell that in this
Why is this reaction used for
D Preparation of So Okay Again I
Already got the questions done from there now
You can see the full reaction
After that because there was 5 mark question
In this and I came this very good if you
If you have done the first part because
There's a little bit of a place where you can be.
Get confused that's why name is ok
The simplest saturated hydrocarbon is
Our methane rises ok come here
It was methane, I told you it was already methane.
Everyone made the electron dot structure.
Will you take it and what type of bond is it?
Here the covalent will be closed and all the bonds
If you are single then you call him single valent.
Bond can also speak if you are normal
Even if you come after writing a bond, what will you do?
Covalent bond will also be fine, it is fine.
Yes CNG and Bio Gas also
Correct CNG and Biogas
very good
Which series is this? Yes, what is written here?
Have you?
will get
ok then this will be your answer and if
If you have done all the parts properly
you will get full marks
Okay, this is our question
If you forget to write the set number ending in
If I go then it won't happen at all mother
Your paper will not be corrected. Don't worry.
About it rate it is not going to change
Un coming tu epic ha epic i was watching
your
Comments Yes going to answer date so you said
Installments Muscles Are Present Correct Stomach
On are but de questions kya tha what
Vas de Cost Question Question I am a
word was given
Date is the first one minute I can do this
it go you back
It is not marked by questions
Have you gone long way back for dat ya
Ok here it is asked come and exit off
So that's why it's okay on both
Helpful tu u ok nine will go back tu d
Place Date See Var In Van Minute
twelfth
yes savita
3 points How much is asked Three points C
Have asked for the three points and rate
Three points ok so 3 points difference
Between nervous and hormonal mechanisms rate
Un Yes So Both Those Things Are There Nine Har C
No Date Nervous System Is About Your Neural
Control and Coordination Chapter Read End
Chemical coordination in D se control and
So what are there in the chapter on coordination
D Three Points Van Point Date You Can
Right is in nervous system actions are
Very quick wear s in d chemical
Coordination actions are pretty slow on
The night sells and our point is this date in
Nervous coordination d information close in
D form of electric impulses right
electric impulses electrochemical
Impulses in the Nervous System Are Chemical
Look at coordination in D form of chemical.
messenger hormone inside third point for
Nervous un sister it's date de flow off
Information South Is Vaidi Nervous Through D
Body Parts But in Case of Chemical
Coordination of hormones when they are
Acting As Chemical Measure Date Time Date Flow
From de blood so date transport cr
Blood worm in nervous system the information
This transport by the nerves is very good
Very good right nine our oxygen related with
D Bending of Light I Have Explained You
This is a well so every what you know unsee no
Date Oxygen Has A Pickle Dominance And
Because of apical dominance it will always move
Towards the direction of light rate they are
Present in de tick witch
D gave oxygen
Meristmatic tips which are where it is
Matrix So In This Case What Happens
This sales rate of oxygen is secreted
Which is present in D
The witch is presented in the dark side, isn't it?
What's in the dark side comes from there
Right
So thoughts are the same because there is more
oxygen
Dat Min's There's An Aane Van
Distribution and Hess The Plant Benz
Towards the Light Direction Next
question
Name D Disorders Name D Disorders and
A Person Likely You Have It Right Name D
Disorder a Person Likely to Have It
From de following and they have also asked
You Name D Disorder Polling Likely OK
Also here there is a question about the right name also.
D Gland Date Secret H of D Hormone
So first of all come
i am happy
J4 You Shot I'm Happy Date The Exam
Well it's so what is it first
Answer What is D First Answer Gauge Over
What does secretion of growth hormone do?
What does it do
do it
it ten di
secreted gland date is
Involved in secretion
Very Good Quote D Pituitary Gland De C
Have deficiency of estrogen
Secreted ovaries in female end
the deficiency of
Sources Actually Regulate
Menstrual Cycle Rate So Date Would Be
Affected if D deficiency of Strauss is
Found next van it less thyroxine then
Thyroxine is secreted by the thyroid.
Gland Hypothyroidism Can the Cost or
The goitre rate can be both.
Have hypothyroidism slow metabolism
Slow Metabolism Weight Gain and Goitre
You know this swelling of the neck
Right
Don't say end puberty, tell him come
Maria Let Love Say Okay Butt Yes
Debt Can Also Be Cost Very Good Very Good
Yes the answer for this van ho is d timing
And amount feedback mechanism and they have
Also asked you explain with the help of
Example so the insulin example can
Take Which Balance the Sugar and Pancreatic
Saras right so date is the correct answer for
date
physics physics
So leave no space here
So let's suppose it is a convex lens.
And object is place this optical center
F1 2f1 and c have every f2n2f2
So Verizon Place D Focal Length Dez F And
D object is placid at distance of you
F So Were Should Be D Object Is At D
Center of curvature which is tough van it
object if object comes dislocation
where should be image
Right value of magnification
And write the value of the verification so
Ho you draw rate diagram for ray which is
Parallel to the principal axis it will pass
tu f tu and d second ray which is passing
Through D Optical Center Will Pass Without
Other Division So This Is D Image
Right but because objective
and d height of d object and height of
D Image Wood B Se Just Date Or Se Height
gauge correct
Change nine D images inverted so height of D
Images are going to be negative so what is
Saying Something Happened What Is
Magnification it is height of the image
Divided by height of d object so nine
There equal in magnitude height of D
Image and height of d object equal in
Magnitude Just Date Images Inverted So
date c mines height of d object so
Magnification It's Going To Be Mines Van
ok yes magnification
Nine D Next Van Student Has Focused
Image
And add couple of slides every
Next
question
ok so length of de flames length of the
Famous 2 Centimeter Height of D Object Witch
Is tu cm nine d focal length is 12 focal
Length is 12 cm but it is witch type
off lens using a convex lens this wood
B plus 12 ok and what else is given d
Distance of de fame from de lance date is
Our You Which Is Mines 16 Centimeters
Tu D Given Principal Axis Calculate D
Value of following you have to calculate
d v and her d length of d image date is
Height of de image dez tu values ​​si have tu
Calculate So Ho Will You Calculate
So what I answer you are going to tell him
D Lens Equation So You Remember What Is
Lance Equation Van Buy C Mines Van Buy You
It will be van by F van by C will be van by
F - 1 / U then substitute the values
What are the values ​​of D focal length and
focal length is plus 12
Mines What Is It You Value Of You Is Mines
16 This Minus 16 Minus Minus Plus So
What is LCM of 12 and 16 LCM is
So 12 * Ho Much Will Give You 48
12*
sorry this van this plus her so this would this
Wood Bee Mines
It should be mines so 12 * 4 - 16 * 3 so
This Van Divided By 48 What Is This
Van By Wee So See Wood B Plus 48 Come So
this is inferior
This is our image distance yes so nine you know
Formula for magnification given height of
D image divided by height of D object
And for D'Lance C have this van as we /
You so height of d image would be by you
Multiply by height of d object so nine
Substitute D Values
So What Is We 48 ​​Mins 48 What Is We
Value of You is Given Today Mines 16 Dec
- 16 * height of object which is 2 less
2 Centimeters and Date Will Give You These Mines
16 * 3 = 48 * 2 less date wood bee mines
Six centimeters give this height of the image
So what is the meaning of negative it means
It is inverted image and height
Wood B Six Centimeters
77 Ho Did You Get 77 You Did A Mistake I
Gas every u see this van by v - 1/u
lance equation
If time mistake other van of you d him
Mirror Equation If You're Right Un Plus Her
And you will get the wrong answer
Right
It's go to next question
and chemistry
I will tell you
In D Group A Group D Group C you
Tell us which one is ours and will be
Lesson 7 And C Are Will Be More Than Seventh
The first part is lemon juice vinegar.
These colorless rated drinks are direct.
If there is acid then there is definitely a lesson here.
will be consumed
Tomato juice and coffee also contain acid
So here also there is a shot, it will be acidic right
Butt kids, what's in ginger juice?
It can also be alkaline sometimes and
Even acidic, we are still according to CBSE.
Will see butt my according s for now
Whatever is there till now I think it is
Must be acidic because here these two
It is acidic, so its also which is good overall.
That lesson will come and the rest will depend on it.
Does answer key pay and this is direct
sodium hydroxide base sodium chloride
Or will it be neutral and lime water is also the base
If so, where will you put Group C?
give grater in 7
Well, as the children said, it is universal.
Indicator or you can also call it paper
Maybe right and second I told you
Because of the F scale you can get away
But we don't get litmus exact.
From there it will basically go to lesson 7 and mode
give 7 ok
Next
Come on then explain the same for
I had also told you about the substance, so here
Substances such as lemon juice that contain copper
Because less effort is required to clean the vessels.
The vessels made of steamed copper are called
It becomes green in color because of
Corrosion rights are basic, basic
When solution reacts with acid
The base reaction takes place and our vessel
he gets clean, ok set three
children are coming
F is important yes great important
In this you see a lot of 3K acid rain.
Questions are from many applications
Whatever you write about this, please write something.
the short it
Ok
ok it's done
I have a question about your bio.
This is repeated a lot, it's okay like this
Whatever the question is, he would have given full marks.
We have it, so why do we basically come here?
I asked a question and gave you some
sa ram story about a sexual end section mode
There are two modes of reproduction named D.
Types of Pigeons Occurring in English Mania
And Plasmodium again on the right
Again the question of excellent
Jollymania is what it is, what it does
What is the binary fusion rate and which is Plasmodium
Has date this multiple fusion been discussed?
Right Van Advantages of Sexual Mode of
Reproduction over asexual mode off
Reproduction So What Was It The Variation
Write it this variation
Variations are good for the survival of D
Organism it is three s dear it is set
three
Now we will do just nine ok c r on
sets van
Red You Have This Question Phone Nice
Fantastic so give de reason same college of
East spread thou multiply in water but in
Sugar Definitely Water Will Not Be Provided
Food sugar carbohydrate will not be available and
Because this carbohydrate is today's source of
Food Right So Hand So Is Required
Carbohydrates Today Source of Food Date This
The Answer for Date Next Rhizopus
Individual Un Rise Opus Is Nothing But You Are
Bread Mode Does Not Grow on Dry Slices
let it moisture you gross
Carbohydrate Food Group Right So
Thoughts the same in't it give name de filament
Structure Name D Filament Structure Date
This student has seen date d student will
See Where They Collect D Water From
The Point Rate and How Do This Organism
multiply date also they have asked so
Very good instructions it is spiro kara raid
Spirocare and others
Spirogyra S Pyrocer Because This
Spirogyra because there are spies etc.
Let's give the date divides and get ten
Reproduction Happen Over Tere Ki
fragmentation there from fragmentation
Reproduction is done right in this way
These are the correct answers to The Hope You Have
Answered all correct
Who have answered all the correct answers for
this
fantastic irish irish tu first now
You 24 Nine C Are On Set Number One And Nine
Let's go start number three and listen last
Question it is one question hydra one
minutes
son hydra first of all did not give it
Algeet Hydra Is Not Films Red They Have
Menshand Filament Structure Hydra Tu Knot
Have filament structure and on d respect
hand hydraulic
and animals
But the set was different
Jones And In Different Zones There Will Be Like
slide change in d difference
Ho Look So I'll Just Quickly Oil You
ho tu solve this so nine every de current de total
Current Witch is Flying Through a Van Will
Split in these days you recombine so again
Total Current Will Split Into Three Again
Recombine So C Will Have Again D Total Current
It Will Not Split Into 4 Different Pathways
Again Recombine Will Have D Total Current Back
So if this current is one ampere in A3 it
Will Also Be Van Amper So What Is D
Relationship between A1 and A3 so A3 will be
Equal Tu A1 Witch Is Just
1 ampere na 1 ampere so nine give you reason
Region Is D Current Splits Recommended
Splits Recombine Splits Again
recombine ok
nine
nine d next question what is d
Relationship between a tu
A3 See Have Van Amperes In A Too Much Current
Will flow in a tu this one ampere current
Will Split Into Four Different Paths And They Have
Equal Resistance Value and Because of Debt
D current split equals so D current in e2
Would be van by fourth of d current in A3 so
Date would be date is d relationship between A2
And A3 So Current In A2 A2 Would Be Just
0.25 amps
ok yes van buy for correct nitish nine
Determine D Reading of D Vote with R V1 So
This Voltmeter Will Measure D Potential
Difference between these points so insta
This I Can Draw a Simple Equivalent
Resistance So What Is D Economy
Resistance it is 3/2 ohm for these two and
What is D Current Total Current It is 1
ampere total current is one ampere so
Potential difference between two points
Only So See Know This Formula V = Irom Law
V =
Resistance 3/2 oh so potential difference
Between 3/2 words and 1.5 V1
ok this answer for d third van 1.5 volt
Nine Find D Total Resistance in D Circuit
Total resistance of D equivalent
Resistance So Her It's Very Simple
Straight Forward So What I Can Do
Equivalent resistance is 3/2 for dies
Three Equivalent Resistance Will Be Just
Van of Dees Four Equivalent Resistance for
m 3/4 oh so d total resistance wood b
total resistance
Or you can write a2s A2 = 1/4 of d A3 dat
You can write down
ok so nine
D Total Resistance Will Be Just 3/2 Witch
this 1.5
+ 3 / 3 which is one of plus three divided
Buy four which is 0.75 ounces and date will come
out you be
3.25 oh this is a total resistance value
Alright, it's easy, not complexity based.
I Was Thinking Actually I'd Get
Something Different Something Very Good Kind Of
Question but this looks very similar to this sir
It seems easy, children can understand it.
I bought this set first
Now let's move ahead
set number three today
Hey hey
In this also children have two questions in Max.
I am different from everyone else, I am each one.
I am going to tell you the answer, are you okay?
Let go
Irish probably missed
It was a while ago and now you
Link will be found in the description box
If you want to prepare for NEET or
Then this is what you have to prepare for.
Our badges are launching soon and
Along with this you will get live free class which
You will see the demo class if you watch
If you want to know how the classes are then you should
He will have to register, okay let's go
So you will take more free demo classes
There are many facilities you can describe
There will be a link in it so you can watch it from there.
ok let's go
completely in english two scores rc run
Different Badges Over There These Are English
once every on youtube
Okay, so for this the answer is very
Good next this is a new question
Select the correct options in the following
Table
Tamarind Tartaric Acid
Yes this is the correct tomato
where is acidic acid no acidic acid
Oxalic in Vinegar Next End String
This is not an acid but methanesic acid.
string methanoic acid
Proper table was given, wasn't it the final?
What will be the answer our first end?
Fort then answer will be for Calcutta yes
Well Vishnu's set has finally arrived
Great let's see the next question this also
Have dan metal with loss density lithium
Which of the following is an example of
Endothermic Process Set Van Questions
[music]
great very good
so it will be done now
Physics is ok after having bio
no2 + o2 the answer will be option number a
What is hydroxide children's product made of?
What is sodium gas + hydrogen gas?
product will be
na2zno2 ok this was also repeated
question
Ok this is a new question which was just asked in the last two
We have not found Select D in the sets.
Correct option from the following is correct
To be correct, salt is the parent acid.
Parent based on nature of salt is salt
I would have written sodium acetate here.
am sodium acetate
ch3coin is sodium acetate
Told you what would you do if you were in salt
If you add water, you will get acid and
base will be found
And this will go oh- so what do we get
acidic acid
plus noh okay so here it is
Parent Acid Acidic Acid Perine Base NOH
butt butt if you only read this much
If you do the first option then the answer will be wrong.
Because the nature here is neutral
Will salt come if there is a strong base then nature?
of salt will be basic right so
Option A is incorrect Sodium carbonate Sodium
If you talk about carbonate then
na2co3 If you add water to it then
I will get noh and carbonic acid right
Noh organic acid so also organic acid
Noh, there is a strong base here this week.
it's acid it's strong
And this is the week so our resulting salt
what will happen to children na2co3 this will happen
Basic and this was study is baking soda
Washing soda is washing soda.
This answer B should have been correct.
But you will have to look at the options once. Sodium
Chloride noh, it is acidic.
No, it is neutral, sodium nitrate
Nitric acid so what will it be?
What if strong becomes neutral?
Therefore this is also wrong This is also wrong Option B
Will be correct answer ok very good 20
True let's next physics question A
Went
All MCQs are almost repeated
Where does the ammeter end in the series?
Voltmeter in parallel option B
Will do it in sleep or lactic acid
Du Tu Lactic Acid C Get D Cramps
we also remembered
Sexual flowers are unisexual flowers.
Option
Fantastic so right now I'm not a kid right now
Started answering sorry very good so it is
Watermill End
Disadvantages
[music]
Left hand rule we have to do it up the current
positive charge going up positive current
going as if the magnetic field is left
hand
Rules Inside
nine resistances
[Laughter]
Because of percentage change and law of your mistake
C Yes Be Correct Vishnu
Let's Find Out First Magnetic Field
Lines Do Not Intersect This Is Correct End
This van is also correct is it A and B
what do i think you
This van is correct explanation of d
True right so what is the answer yes the for
Delhi correct let's move next
Ok this is a new question let's solve this
So here what is the angle through which de way
passing through de prince
Call it an unrefracted ray and this is final
emergency
Right so this is the direction of D
Incident Light And This Is D Over
Emergency So D Angle Between Instant Re
And emergency is called as angle of division
Nine Read D Assets Again So What It Is D
angle
Provisions Will Pass Through The Prism So
This ray which is inside refracted ray
Don't see it's refractive it's inside it
Prism What Do C C C C D Incident
Re&Cd Emergency Tree So See Can
Only Look Aate Deez Tu So
Correct is called as angle of division this is
Correct Vishnu
it correct it
[music]
Unique Shop Right and Because of Date It Max
Un emergence rap bend aate aate de angle tu de
Incident Ray So Date Is D Angle Between
Incident Re and D Emergency So Again
what is this angle between this is an
Incident Re&D Emergency Tree This
angle of division so and d region correct it
So Reason It's Not Just Correct It Is Un
Correct Explanation
what is written
gave him the definition refracted line
Na this through de prism through
Out of D Prism D Race Not Within D
Prism it has already come out there is
Meaning of through a prism so it is called
As angle of division
Let's Next Van Bacteria
This Dividing Continuously Continuously
Today has given you this generation generation tu
There is no change as no sexual reproduction
There is no change because they are close
Right Yes Yes Right Give Coping Inverse Mall
In accuracy so this is also true and d
Respect thing is also true rate both are true
And social is also true and the reason for this
Also true but the reason is not the correct
Explanation for a date is the correct
Answer: B.B. Write it, you are B.B., right?
Because reason is not the correct explanation
There is no change in this region.
Section Reproduction You Have a Single Parent
In Sexual Reproduction You Have More Aa
Variation Due Tu Tu Parents Right
butt correct
This is also correct Reason is also correct
An op is also correct but reason is
So should you get the full answer right?
inst b
It won't happen like this but because
Denim variation is not an occurrence variation will
oker but after so winnie generation itna
Generation I will go away from the camera
The rate will be so much that it will take one generation to copy red DNA.
Invoice mall in accuracy which is correct
for both d
Things Rich Correct Explanation The Correct
Are you saying that DNA copy is involved?
mall in accuracy rate what are you saying
is correct, both regions are also correct
The explanation is
It is not the case here that divides in
Result in two bacteria and again four
Bacteria Produce Wood B Almost
Similar Same Are They Almost Similar De Region
There is involvement of single parent
Always remember that the involvement of
Single Parent Result Small Variations
over you
Coping with it is a common step for both sexually
and sexual reproduction
yes this is so google
there
right so
Someone must have created it in Google
Na it's a very good thing to do
Needed
if if
you about date
Is no great in accuracy when we talk
About dna copy method in sex
Reproduction as well
Right So In Date Way You Have You Think
I hope so because you will get the mark
What will be my right?
Question So every this graph this voltage
Vs current so d slopes what is d
slope slope is voltage versus voltage
Divided by current which is nothing but
Resistance So Higher D Slope Higher Wood B
D resistance so resistance of b is
give greater resistance off
Greater Than Resistance of a But Nine
From diameter date mains from area and because
Of Debt Resistivity Of Being It Greater
Than the resistivity of a so what is d
Answer witch of d tu material have d higher
Resistivity it is DB has been higher
Resistivity
Sir I am going back to the previous question again.
I am because the concept is a bit messed up
My children are gone and there is no trace of them here.
Copy of Why You Wish You Were In Sexual
There are more errors in reproduction
Buddy
It is not called no error, it is called recombination.
DNA comes from two parents.
C Call It Us DNA Recombination Because Of
Which sea has different features is not that
Variation in our
There Can Be DNA Errors in More
If there are more errors in sexual reproduction
Lagte toh there wood have bin ek kam nahi a
someone's asking someone's question
I don't know, the third eye is coming, it would be right.
So it doesn't happen son, there are variations there.
More people come there because
The second factor is called witch
Recombination which you learn in higher grades of
We haven't been told the course yet, we call it
DNA recombination and many more
There are factors how far away is Lagos
How close is it and where is the combination taking place?
The rate of recombination is very high.
Because of that he becomes rich but yes
Of the temperate bacteria I am saying
clone but think of temperate bacteria
ok so what they said is temperate
bacteria means date they talk about r's
bacteria
there is more sex
Chromosomes come right so two I snuff
Where in bacteria his live is small
His circular DNA is in date way if you're
Saying Correct Reading Between the Lines
Very important over every one so small to us
Little information is given but yes I really
Hope I'm Also Wanting You Maybe You
People please correct yourself, ok and really
hopping you have a date
Son, how many times have we done digestion?
Times See Have Dan Immersion of Fact
Immersification of fat and pancreatic juice
How are alkalines and what are they?
D Pancreatic Zoom Juice Pancreatic
Amylist for Carbohydrate Undigestion
And the trypsin for protein digestion yes
Ammilion Types Very Correct Alkaline
are so de maintain the f of un di
Small Intestine Right D Secreted
Secret occurs in the duodenum, this is right
So right for domestic let's move ahead
Let's move on, the next question is
of Chemistry
ok what is observer n one solution
Children, I have asked this question many times today.
I am asking the question for the third time
So let me tell you the final answer.
Let me give you what is observed
Solution of potassium iodide is mixed
with
So kids have double displacement reaction
and you will get yellow color
LED double displacement you can call it
This is precipitation reaction guys right
ok after that sleep also type of reaction
Right D chemical equation then which reaction
Is it double displacement or you
Precipitation can also be called that, ok
So this is our first part chemical
We told you in the reaction that we did this also
What if copper powder is added to a watch glass?
When hit, it reacts with oxygen
Karo forms copper oxide which is black.
The substance is ok, so this is the first thing for you.
Have asked vice this black substance form
Because copper and both oxidation also form
copper oxide name copper oxide work and
Ho can this black substance also be reversed?
You guys will give the answer in the original form.
Because I have told you many times
Very Good Vishnu Yes You Will React Copper
Oxide with hydrogen C will get copper
And water back is ok so very easy question
Came many times and discussed with
This is over, now the next question will come.
Bio question
I think
If you had told me the law then it would have been 100% ours.
what is hundred percent
Right and what is the correct answer for
This is the reason given here only.
What answer will tall plaster off children tell?
Its Law of Domino Fantastic Aa What
Wood B D Ratio Of Plant Of 10 Come On
Tel me three is tu van phenotypic ratio
Genotypic ratio 1:2:1 thought to be correct
Answer for date yes
My Lastik Let's Go Ahead
Ok
Brother I've damned it you can go back and
Rewatch Sir, I am speaking after thinking about you first.
don't repeat
[music]
Yes Yes Yes New Van Wright Ozone Alto and
Deadly Poison Performs and Essentials
Function for the Earth and its Inhabitants
Explain so ozone is a deadly poison
Which is very true rate but one is also
Ozone is a deadly poison
Poison when not in the stratosphere
It's red it should be in D
Stratosphere If It Is on the Earth's Surface
In last class we have discussed this if
It is on the Earth's surface What it is
A poisonous gas which can burn us
Respiratory System Red So Thoughts Very
What is dangerous but an essential function?
Essential Function Is Date It Block DUC
Radiation too come on the surface because of witch
C R Only D It Can Prevent
The Fantastic Right Protects From The Yes
Ruqaiya protects from those who see them
Skin Cancer Immune Disorders Can Be a
Avoided Cr Se From Date
Yes next one please ok so next
Chemistry question has come to an end in new
question
[music]
Must define oxidation children
Reaction with oxygen or loss of hydrogen
You can say ok the van came to the mark
Tha I hope everyone would have written next
let's see the question
oxidizing agents in the following
Reactions and Balance the Chemical Equations
Here you are given equations.
First of all they have to balance
Balance here, see there is only one PV.
If there are three here, then three will come here again.
Now we can see what happens after that
If chlorine is visible then there is only one
only chlorine chlorine 2 2 * 3 = 6 + 2 wich
If this 8 comes here then h2 is here.
It's here pe 8x so here pe four aayega to
Now watch oxygen oxygen here 4
I have 4 here, I have my balance yes.
yes of course
is here
Here you are and oxygen 3 is here
If there is three then it will be 3/2 then the whole equation
If we multiply by 2 then you will get this
Four, sorry, 3/2, it's three here.
Will come again you are here 2 will come
hey look at that
The session may or may not last for 5 hours or continuously.
This is balance
Whose was it? You guys also did this, right?
I understood
[music]
Well, this is clear, now tell me quickly
What are oxidizing agents?
See Right Carbon and Compound Dia You Can
Right date no issues or Nitish tell me what
de oxidizing agent har so pb4 is
changing tu pbcl2 and water and kal
Stitching Tu cl2 So First of All See Can
Identify from every loss of hydrogen
mains
taking place
Come on, Vishnu said, reduce this tomorrow.
Okay, so at least you told me the final answer.
What is the scene of oxidizing?
agent here
I have to go, you guys write what are we?
so been talking for a long time
If you are three then children, this oxidation is happening.
If it is then it will be the reducing agent and this
will be ours
The first one will be pv3o4 ok very
Good next look here what is this
If there is loss of oxygen then reduction will happen.
What will happen if there is oxygen?
oxidizing agent will
B here mno2 and aluminum what will
b di oxide
Yes yes Amit let's so this is what reduction
And this is oxidation addition of oxygen so
Reduction is happening this will be
oxidizing agent oxidizing agent
will be m and o2
Well, will it last longer? Let's sit down for less.
Friend, it will be done in 5 minutes, okay, let's go.
[Laughter]
change tu green
Coaching formed on the surface of copper
What will happen if copper reacts with A which is
What happened to our CO2 gas in our air?
Have h2b, sorry are saying h2, also have h2o
And we also have oxygen, okay?
Overall, what will this reaction do to you?
You will get Copper Carbonate + Copper
Hydroxide, children, this is a mixer.
Its color is green so if you
Have asked what is causing the green color?
Copper carbonate is coming due to mixer
Plus Copper Hydroxide and Joe Mist Gas
is a which is that children a will b c o
You are right, this will be our reaction
Are there any questions after this? Yes sir
It will be better after this again
Our question is, let's see next.
Looks like all the chemistry has been given.
I have
Yes it is done, after this it is copper
Ocean and hosting difference had to be explained and then
There was a further question, here he gave it
It is specifically about copper, so copper
The side that faces children is copper.
If sulphide is fine then what will happen in it?
We will react as we are and what will happen to it?
Roasting
ok hosting means because sulphide
will be hosting
Sir, I am missing food and feeling hungry.
Tell me, we are feeling very hungry.
Is
finish it quickly ok then here
If we react with oxygen, we will get
What will we get? We will get copper.
oxide + so2 gas ok kids over here
You were required to do the balancing equation if
If you did it then it's okay, if you didn't do it then too.
It's okay because it's not good here
Brother, you have not said the chemical equation.
I had to come back after balancing. When I came home, it
This does not mean that marks will be deducted if taxes are there.
very good no calcification
Calcination and not be late because you know
The reaction will take place in the presence of
Oxygen in Axis of Oxygen for Sulphide
Ho nine what will happen see go this nine copper
Sulfate Again Reacts With Cu2o And See Will
gate copper plus so2 gas
Right this is going to be our reaction
We will get all the copper here but I
Once I calcination yes correct then
We cannot extract from carbonate side
It is given in it that you get sulphide.
Balance has to be done immediately with sulphide road.
I will also write down the chemical reaction of
Here this will happen, you and this will happen
Six you will get the exact here
Solid is gas and if here we
If you look here, 2 3 2 and 2 is ok.
This will be the final expression here
Our right is fine, come on sir, we said it now
go ahead
Yours
Write So What It Means By Expression
Elimination of Nitrogen and Waste from D
Body
Ok
Urinary Bladder State Function Who Can Answer
me date
Connecting D Urinary Bladder Who Can Give
me d answer
it asked
For this I also told Fantastic Double
The one with double eyes, the one with single eyes
Don't come by writing. Spelling right correct yes.
Correct Nations Correct Carriages Urine from the
Kidney Collect the urine from the kidney and
Take It Too D Urinary Bladder Fantastic
Fantastic so what is the answer for this
uritos right ureters of d first answer
For date status function you told you
Function Nine Let's List Your Factors
Factors on which the amount of water is
Absorption Is Dependent Or Can You Tell Date
ok no problem can you oil dat or d
First they have asked for tu tu van ise
water in 10
ACT hormone
amount of water
Regulation Also Controls So If in Respect Case
If it is possible that my child has
The option is not to drink only two.
Dependent isn't it so if you have retained
Andar Option What jump is the Andar Option
For this day and there option jump b intake off
Caffeine Rich in Take Off Caffeine and Alcohol Date
Will Also Increase the Amount of
Factors including the amount of water required
Absorption depends on water wood b
Decrees in case of alcohol in take and
Café in Take Us Well So These Are the Reasons
Ok
I wrote it by mistake
In human respiratory system name the
following
Slow and board is kind of flashing on
My mother, I am studying from a distance.
ok part ware is filtered by fine
Haze and mucus lining de van gas
fantastic nose
What is the matter?
Ok
fantastic
cavity from the abdomen dome
Shaped cavity and abdomen dome shape
What it is called us
Yes seriously I also saw this un pointed
Bye
Physics very easy I don't know same sodium
Biology Without Diagram Paper First Ever
Time
exchange take place tell me bhaiya grapeship
aloe veras aloeveli tu badi air passage date
lead you from the trachea to the lungs
So this one of ours is from the C ring structure.
what do we call it if it remains
It's bronchial, isn't it? Then it goes away.
Becomes free in the lungs
All the answers are correct. Next
question
B's A1 has become your list and you are
Characteristics of Long Witch Make and
Efficient Respiratory System This Is An
pickup
This is d pick repetitive question for
Previous year question paper son is ok
This was in the previous I Gives 2022 paper
List other characteristics of Long
Which makes it more efficient respiratory
Software Because of the N Number of End
Willis rate it great
Absorption Office Are Given You D Fan
Facts If You Remember If Stretching Out D
Human long it can be come on the 10th
size rate so date is given
Greater Area of ​​Exchange
Image
Just write down the answer for this - 36
centimeter and for this it is -6 centimeter
These questions are in all three sets
I'm someone asking for you again there
Also Se Questions Repetitive Questions You
Can't Just Go Back and Look Next Van
Mom whose chemical is this?
[Laughter]
The date which comes in the food chain is
Biomagnification and respect region for this is
There Tropic Level Highest Traffic Level
Humans live there in T4.
Thoughts the Same D Biomagnification Is Always
Higher in D Topic Level
happens the most
Nine Tu Factors Magnetic Field OK
We have done this many times
Factors on which magnetic field depends
Just only you factors na and first it
magnetic field is directly
Proportional to current second is
Magnetic field is inversely proportional
Tu D Distance Only Dz Tu Factors Current
End Distance for D Straight Conductor
OK State D Rule Which Determine Direction
Off the magnetic field which rules you date
This Called Right Hand Thumb Rule
Ok
Current Industries Carrying Conductor & D
Magnetic Field Wood B in D Concentrics
Circles Dz R
Concentric Circles Kinetic Full Going
These words are coming out these days
Concentric circle de is de magnetic
Field Pattern for D Street Conductor Ise
Nine Name D Hormone Release End D Gland
Secrets in Humans I'm Wrong
What should be the answer name D hormone?
Release and repetitive question sir door
Sir, tell me, the children will tell me this morning when
He has gone to the examination hall
I found out right now so it gave it to me
right from d adrenal gland adrenaline
Red Aate This Is Actually Called Aaj Di
Emergency Hormone What Does It Do?
actually
heart rate
Three points over system and hormonal such
It seems that I have given the same thing and it is working for me.
Right on between Nitish Vasta Asking D
Fan Fact Isn't So D Fan Fact About D
Longest date if you spread out your long
An they will become one it will become one because
A half tennis court is so big that it takes too long.
Dates Are Like 600 Million Aloe Vera It
Present Over Give So Greater Absorption
Capacity
porus
every ok
Density nine was uncoordination 1 minute
Difference between nervous and hormonal
Mechanism of Control and Coordination Yes
Just Watch Making Shok It's D Se Question
And it's like little beet cute
So How Each of the Three Different Nervous Systems Works
With the Knobs Definitely Chemical System
Works with the blood transport system
In chemical coordination we have hormones in
Coordination C Have Electrochemical
Signals Nervous Coordination Gives You
Quick response and it's on site
Where Are Chemical and Coordination Is Not You
D Side All Ways Not Just Tu Un Single
point butt words
And it may be quick and it may not be quick
again
Related To The Bending Of The Plant Again
The Same Question Yr Go Back and Check It's OK
So oxygen shows the apical terminals it is
Present in these tips it is unsmoked
By de best matic tissues in de tips and
On de honor hand one un ho it secreted
If the D.R. Nucleus Was Just Telling It For
Then if the light is falling on this side
Oxygen will be secreted when it is darker.
Side Not On This Side Red
So what's this secret?
Jobs You Know Yourself Increase Number of Sales
Chris un so here pe de number of sale will
Increase and because the cell number increases
In Which Direction It Will Bend To Respect
Van, you are also a state level player, right?
Let's go ahead or
[Laughter]
You give dem a name of the gland so it's
un pituitary gland estrogen over
Secretion Will Lead Not Deficiency They Have
As So Difficult Wild Lead You Irregular
Masural Cycle Weight Gen
Delayed Puberty Red and Honor It Is
Secreted Key D Ovaries in D Female Letts
Secretion of thyroxine can result in
Hypothyroidism Were in There This Slow
Metabolism of Carbohydrates Fats and
Protein because of which you will have increased
Wait and Next Another Thing You Can Also
Give the Name of Goitre Over Her
Comment nine so it should be like
Reply it life
Yes we are very much and we can very much
Answers and C are every from 1:30 pm on
Word
Continuously going with this full energy
I am already
[music]
skip it
Coming to next question
I have already told the questions to the children
If you go back a little you will get it.
Already told twice, ok I am
Sir, you guys have done it, let's come.
We move on to the next question
This van ok hydrocarbon is this what happened
and focal length is
so inferior object distance
ok this object place d focal length is
15 So Focal Length This Unconcave Mirror Focal
Length is -15 cm so object is
Place Object Between Center of Curvature
A&D Principal Focus
new question
[Laughter]
Tha I'm solving come what de distance
C want you calculate what it is dv
Ho are you calculate si have tu him yes this
D se questions i gas these these questions
In Ur NCERT Textbook Direct
Question Three Mark Question C I
From NCERT Textbook
And what is the formula of van by c
plus van by u hee it van by f so
Salt it, I will write the final answer, I will be.
Mines 75 / 2 Centimeters Directly From
Your NCERT and Find D Nature Size of
D Image So Images For Her Nature Is This
This is magnified it is inverted under
Real and d height of d image would be six
centimeter
Alright very easy question from your
NCRT nine list other users of D
Concave Mirror Where You Use Concave Mirror In
torch torch
What's going to happen to this one, kids? Is this going to happen?
Why would acid go because lemon is here
Juice is right, citric acid is vinegar.
Colorless drinks contain acidic acid
What is the meaning of 'f' in these also?
Lesbians will definitely learn a lesson.
After that tomato juice and coffee are also acidic
Ginger juice is sometimes alkaline too.
This happens because it depends on the answer.
CBSE will give you according to it.
I will see his butt according to my answer.
It should happen that only lesson 7 will come here because
We have two substances you know which
Sodium hydroxide is acidic.
Chloride lime water is neutral but
Children, what a strong base these two are.
The F that comes here should be greater, 7 will come.
Ok
You have read the Way of Determining
Universal indicator and litmus paper aap bol
Can you or will the concentration come out h+
ion from there f paper help sorry f scale
With the help of this we will be able to get rid of
Because it contains citric acid 11th
In and When Copper Gets Tarnished Children
So what happens is it turns green
If it turns green then it is ok
Acid base reaction will be cleaned.
Because of this, I have read a lot of F's important books.
I'm not going to tell you right now it's over you
The next question for the exam
question
How come the children don't know English?
produces binary fashion
Plasmodium Wright Van Advantage Variation
a lot happens here
sexual reproduction
The food is better than water and it has no energy.
not available and rice vice pe meaning
Our bread does not grow properly.
You know the answer is not there so right
By the way, some of your children are appreciated.
After the arrival of the paper they are doing this
Right N Filament Structure Film Inter
Structure that will meet the water of the pond
Spirogyra end will be obtained from water
Spirogyra Will Divide By
Fragmentation
fantastic
So A3 D current in A3 would be from as a van
Wrote that solution
[music]
This will come soon three
son we
Final Answer A Tu Is Equal Tu A3 / 4 Which
It is divided into van by four amps and 0.25 amps.
i am doing
I'll write it down to 1.5 volts you can
Go This Question Too Times I Am
Doing and De Total Resistance Date Would Be
3 Point Something 3.25 Ounce Total Resistance
Because this would be 3/2 and 1.5 arms this
One off and this is 0.75 ounces they are in
parallel they are in parallel there are in parallel so
If you add the three so they would be in series
Date Will Come Out Tu B 3.25 Om So Date Is
D final answer
Alright for today
[music]
And the children have also been with us for a long time.
Connected so gas keep it up you guys
showed great dedication
After the class exam you know very
Nice design
How much more hard work needs to be done and how much more
Want to get more marks right thank you
So much all of you please go and link right
Please go to the link and check on
Reporter ok you will find this link
What Do You Have in D's Features Over Her
You may like classes that have recordings
If you get to see the recordings too
quiz personal
And D Examination Flashcard Revision
Animated Videos What's Not Everything Is
There will be something and yes so click here
On this link ok click here
Do it, go and book the free demo so date.
You Can Get in These Classes and You Can Be
On this board my my wish is actually all off
All Special Date Next Time This Picture Should
Replace with your photos right date is what
C Want So Thoughts What An J And This Is
For below gas d se process ok so c
have d thing this
Enrollment Has Not Started Just Take It
Out and Let's Rockers Thank You People Okay So
Thank You Everyone Now See Will By Enjoy And
Take Care and All the Best for Your Next
exam by
guy to bother you